This episode of Your Mom's house is brought to you by Saatva luxury mattress,
the only online mattress company that provides free delivery set up and mattress
removal.
Well,
no,
go to your mom's house,
Christina.
Oh Man.
A lot of crazy things happening.
Uh,
this episode's going to be nuts,
but,
um,
we've been adding a lot of dates on this tour if you don't know yet.
Uh,
the 2019 tour for me
is blown up.
Added a second show,
San Francisco at the May Sonic.
That's January 4th.
Uh,
San Diego.
We sold out two.
We added a third January 12th.
That's almost gone.
So I don't know if we're going to add again after that.
Oklahoma City,
San Antonio,
Houston,
Dallas,
they're all on sale.
Tom [inaudible] dot com slash tour.
Um,
and the added shows have been happening left and right.
The most recent ad,
I can't even tell you,
actually I don't remember,
but it might be another Seattle show went on sale.
That's in May,
May 3rd,
uh,
just go to the site and,
um,
grab tickets.
I'll see you guys in Pachangas that sold out.
Um,
next week.
Gene.
What about you?
Alright,
gene.
This Saturday I edit a late show,
uh,
in San Diego at the House of Blues.
That's November 24th.
A few tickets left on that late show.
So snatch him up now.
Uh,
December 1st.
Flappers comedy club in the side room.
I'm doing a seven 30 to nine 30 show and then a December 7th Philadelphia late
show.
Just a handful of tickets left on that one.
December 8th.
Gramercy theater,
same deal.
Um,
yeah.
December 8th new Jude or titties and then a January 10th at the comedy store.
January 31st through February 2nd,
I'm in Denver,
Colorado at comedy works.
And then in February in Madison,
Wisconsin,
the comedy club on state.
I'm doing the ride or die tour.
You can check out the tickets at Pristina p online.
Nice.
You go denim.
All right.
Don't forget,
uh,
the degenerates of course on Netflix.
He's and uh,
instant family.
It's in theaters right now.
Go check it out right now.
Right now.
Hope you enjoy it.
A lot of people have told me that they laughed and cried and they're upset that
they cry.
Alright.
It terrible.
Is it?
Time is time.
It is time.
The great,
you might know him as sickle cell,
but
you'll always be known as the Great Ryan sickler
something man.
It's like a son to me.
Hear the new album is out.
It's currently number.
Why?
Ah,
it's Ryan sickler.
Get a hold of yourself.
What's keeping it 11 go try it.
Check it out.
Try it out and I'm,
let's do a proper show open and get this whole thing started.
All right,
here we go.
I know Christina will like this one.
Here we go,
Jane.
Okay.
I turned it to a telescope.
When I see your pains,
you feel so good to me.
They would not meet you and you tell to me,
I want you to milk me like hot chocolate and candy and not with high bro.
You melt me every day.
Oh is Randy.
Don't bring anyone in loving to this.
Well,
welcome.
Go to your mom's house.
I thought you would dig that video because it was like a really smooth,
like I talking to you.
Yeah.
Chicks.
I couldn't,
I couldn't get past his teeth.
What was wrong with it too?
Uh,
can I tell you what I've all of that I wanted to,
I had two questions.
One,
where the fuck did that guy get a cell phone and sunglasses in prison.
He's in prison.
The dental work and the haircut or prison appropriate but the cell phone and a
fucking song.
Last cell block bees over there.
Again,
fucking shout out.
I just always fascinating
by the length,
the depth that men will go to.
I mean all of us want to get laid,
but like,
like you know,
some people just out there like I'll make you calm guy.
Yeah.
Well they throw it out there too hard.
It's not,
it's not always a good approach.
Oh,
this great snack day.
I've been looking at your picture so low and they met and they magnify my Eyes
Bay.
Oh see what happened was your picture did that to his eyes.
Oh,
telescope the telescope.
I turned it to a telescope.
When I see your pain,
what do you see your baby,
they would not meet you.
Are you talking to me?
I want you to milk me like hot chocolate and candy and not with high bro.
Well,
we cool hot breath.
You melt me every day.
Prison poetry,
right?
Yeah,
that is.
You know what though?
I know why this works.
I know why guys are,
please tell us I got it because it does work and it,
because every woman deep down inside wants to be told this stuff.
Maybe not that Shell.
Yeah.
Not In that presentation,
but we all want to hear that.
You want that candy bar just not that route.
That's right.
Thank you very much.
Yes.
Look how handsome Ryan sickler looks at you.
Dude.
Thanks.
Look,
get a hold of yourself.
I like this title.
I appreciate it.
See,
there's different guys who put it out there in different ways.
I don't know if you've ever,
God,
yeah.
Price.
You go or you can just make club to someone they know
and then in the morning they go there where you go your way.
Yeah.
Prostitutes.
What's he watching in the background?
That's always the question.
It was Rachel Maddow.
I wish I was like,
I didn't feel good.
This guy from Msnbc type,
but this right here,
right
are felons.
Nothing.
Just have straight up sex,
buy a house cleaning question clean.
Because for my buddy Matt was good down there,
you know bound their crane guys are always worried about that.
Yeah.
And also I think he put his teeth in just for this.
Well different different videos he had.
He treats you differently.
So this is one without
sure.
Toss any heavier.
Yeah,
they should be somebody out there wants to hook up Casper.
Yeah.
I wish you a rich woman
and then he's nice enough to be like,
I'd be nice if she was rich to take.
Here's the thing about that,
there is someone out there,
someone else there was like,
I'm here.
Me,
somebody did a,
reached out to him and then he put his teeth in.
Hello out there.
Hello.
Hope you're doing great kids.
A lot better.
Look for me.
Yeah,
I like those too.
Thank you for all the vagina.
Any shots?
Very nice.
Everything about it is like the lighting is better.
His energy is like,
it definitely is fired up.
He also let me bit between the teeth.
He also meets the,
uh,
your mom's house criteria of having the television on,
in the background and loudly so that he records his audio and that audio at the
same time.
Loud.
Beautiful,
warm Herman aren't here.
They get shit.
God don't look oh great.
Hello.
Stay with you longer.
Cheat on you with another one.
They won't cheat on you with another guy.
All right.
Is that the sales page for you though?
I love all his nick backs back there.
Do you see him?
Well Ryan,
I don't know if you're familiar with the criterion for your mom's house video,
but a,
the lighting has to be garbage.
Uh,
be the shot.
The shot has to be bad too.
It's gotta be shot from down here.
Uh,
there's these would be like a fan or something in the background that's even TV.
Audio has to be poor you about the box.
Have you,
um,
I'm so excited to get to this,
that jumping all around.
First of all,
why don't we book boyfriend?
Glad I love Ryan Ziglar.
He's the bachelor nights.
So the album,
uh,
where did you record the album?
I'm not allowed to say really mad.
They made me sign saying,
oh,
you probably know by me saying that,
but they made me sign a deal.
I was like,
I'd be happy to promote that.
And they're like,
nope.
So they wouldn't let me say,
but it was in southern California.
Okay.
And what's the,
um,
I'm not even gonna,
I'm not trying to pry to get it,
but like,
you know,
what's the,
uh,
did they say don't,
you're not allowed to say,
I don't know.
I don't know if it's part of like,
they don't want any war.
Everyone thinking they can come and do that.
You know what I mean?
I don't know.
Maybe it's the riff raff thing or,
because usually the places are happy to have the hook,
that ship mode or large print.
Yup.
Okay.
Um,
but you recorded it at a Anaheim Angel Stadium.
100 people show it was in the dug out.
That's what we sell.
That's where we start to PAC man.
Right.
It wasn't anything.
That was it.
I had High Bay village volt asleep.
Roy fires though.
Firestone.
Guys,
guys.
My favorite thing when the two of you get together because I've known you too.
I consider you a brother Ryan.
Thank you.
Sickle cell.
I've known you for 15 years.
I was just thinking about the other night.
It's been at least that maybe more.
You've been a guest in our home for holidays,
thanksgivings,
everything.
And my favorite thing when you come around is that you like Tommy up.
That's really the two of you.
What can we load?
So I know,
I'm telling.
Look at this.
Happy it been all day.
He's got that guy's teeth in right on the two wheeler.
Better start talking like black guys immediately.
Yeah.
You start yelling and black the minute you get.
All right.
Did you just did it in the dugout while we were yelling at Pac man?
Just yelling.
Yeah.
Oh,
it was not yelling and black.
I don't know.
I don't know if we would call it black and black.
Black Boys.
Um,
in a funny black boys.
The,
uh,
Oh,
you have brothers?
I do.
Did you ever smoke meth with him?
Never ever thought about it.
I have smoked weed with both my brothers and that's as far as my drug really
goes anyway.
I'm not crate.
They,
they've done a lot more stuff.
But you're someone who I always wanted to show this to.
Um,
smoke man.
Do you know about this guy?
The Ma,
the math guy?
Sure.
Let me get a look at them.
I'm not good with names.
Let's see.
Okay.
Do you pay any kind of disorder?
Oh,
it's the same.
Okay.
Forget that bag or forget about salads.
Forget that.
And Dick and plants and all that stuff.
So I don't know.
Can you believe me or not?
God Damn it,
man.
You like this seem you smoked meth with a small limp Dick.
Did Dad get hardly any other way and why did you get harder and harder than
Laura?
Smoke harder?
My Dick get this.
Unbelievable.
He's,
first of all,
he's making edits on this video.
Oh,
you know,
it's interesting.
Every time someone new comes and sees it,
they add a layer.
You're right.
But let's,
can we go back nearly halfway?
Yeah.
Can we go have a relative of my cousins and Emma,
this is like a halfway house clearly want to go back to Christina's last point
of what great framing and
it's all there man.
These guys are all under your,
under your Chin is a layer is a layer in the,
uh,
in the criteria.
Is it also a ridiculous ask?
Cause this guys that you want to see me as moment,
it was a little dig and then to get harder and harder to take like a Choo Choo
train.
The other guys,
like if you just want to send me some pussy shots and panty shot,
it's always over.
And
that's actually probably the production value because there's edits.
Yeah.
And then,
and then it goes to every right,
the [inaudible] near the top.
Yeah,
but wait,
it's,
so,
here's the best part.
As ridiculous as that is this,
uh,
this was the lowest most,
this is the least ridiculous point of this video.
Let me continue playing this for you.
Hey,
you won't believe how good it feels.
Good.
If you're straight,
he won't believe how good it feels.
You're drinking it become so sensitive that you don't need lube.
We don't need spirit.
True Dick,
head this up and down four times.
It's this hot bed and doing shit and normous Dick Dick Hot White Cup.
Hi Is this is,
this guy's not a veteran at this.
He's a veteran like that's how deep he is.
Four Times.
He knows all the steps.
Wait,
hold on.
You haven't even heard the best it
and then I've ever done in my life.
I know I'm gay.
I love it.
Get blowjobs and I'd tell you what,
I cannot wait when I'm so fucked up and hot and Horny home,
man,
I,
I lay any days that can get me a book.
Just anybody can do it.
I mean,
it's friendly about it.
Well,
here's the best part.
My brother didn't believe me that when he smoked with me,
he put his dick.
I can't believe how big his dick was.
He checked off him for stroke and shot the most common every time.
He's like,
he's only 49 and he's fine.
He has known the rock with the problems at home.
They
a lot.
All the broader,
thicker and even more coming believes me.
Now you believe in that.
This guy just told the world his brother smoking meth with him,
whip to stick out and shot a load bigger than he's ever,
ever has an all 49 of his years.
That's unbelievable.
Are you going to do that with your brother?
I can't wait.
I can't wait for Christmas.
We got something else to do now.
Do you want to see me go from a limp Dick?
Too hard.
What did it this weekend and I'll video tape it.
Got It
smaller.
He's using bill.
Same video tape or there and harder.
Right?
And let me know.
That bothered me a bit.
If you say yes,
I'll show it to you.
Okie dokie.
Why does he have to keep reiterating?
Mining is in a halfway house and just off camera to somebody over here playing
solitaire on a car.
Somebody here's got some pieces.
I know exactly.
I don't even give up
their blog.
Now you,
whatever Larry's at.
And again,
in a lot for stroke.
I,
um,
I was back in Baltimore for my shows this weekend.
And,
um,
I went to a ravens game and you know,
we make fun of the Baltimore accent all the time.
And I heard so many really good,
uh,
just one liners,
but with that accent.
But the one that stood out to me was this guy.
We're all in line at the urinal and it's,
you know,
it's like five,
six people deep.
Each one of them,
there's always the one guy,
he's entertaining the whole bathroom and he starts talking about if you had to,
would you eat your own Dick?
You know,
and that's in the bathroom.
This is the question he presents to a public men's restroom and everybody this
area or this corner where he is over there all starting to talk about it.
And one guy's like,
first dig in,
my math ain't go be by Dick.
I got teeth,
Pinky toes,
it one dick and I'm gonna eat my pinky toes first.
So they keep going and he's like,
I'm going ask it,
a buddy of mine and we got to die.
You got to eat meat.
I eat you.
And finally this one salty dude in the back gets tired of it and he just goes,
put your dick away in,
move on.
When I started fucking laugh.
It's so God the dude put your Dick away.
He's up there all talking to people and he's like,
put your take away immovable on phones too as a two syllable.
And that was a lot of fun
by the dawn's early.
Why
is that?
He has to wait.
Some bothers you.
The,
he has to keep saying if you want to go from just a little too hard over and
over fucking 10 times because he's actually trying to see who's excited about
it.
You know,
he's trying hard and because there's somebody,
there's guys that they were like,
fuck here there are Arctic.
Yes,
and also my little Dick.
I want it to get hard.
We now to make sense of the,
I want to show you the submission so badly.
So are you familiar with this?
Right?
Are you familiar with good morning Julia.
I mean so far I'm over here and that's sad.
It's like we're going to be consistent here.
You hear that?
You heard that?
You know what that was Joe show,
isn't it?
But you know who this is the morning Julia,
try it guy.
No.
Okay,
fantastic.
He has no idea.
So let me just give you a little background.
So we were actually supposed for people that don't know,
we were actually going to talk to her last week,
Julia,
Julia.
But the fire's created like kind of,
you know,
this has,
we had kind of left here on a different day.
We're going to have her on,
hopefully I'll say hopefully next week.
We actually found Julia,
um,
Julia is a young lady who one day
had an encounter with this individual and the next day.
And by the way,
she wasn't like,
what are you doing?
We've got like to talk to you more.
She just met this dude.
And then like,
where do you know,
I believe the store at the,
at the gym.
So publicly,
yeah.
The,
the story of what was being passed around was that she met him at a bar and she
let me know.
She goes,
that's not true.
I didn't meet him at a bar.
A shot,
I'll give you the full story and I was told that the correct story is that they
go to the same gym and he just happened to pick up on her name and somehow got
her info.
She spoke to him like like,
hey,
how's it going at the gym?
And then next day opens her phone and gets this on her.
Oh Good Morning Julia.
Meet Gel.
Just wanted to say hi.
Wish you a great day.
Tell you that meeting and you yesterday and getting a look at you was probably
one of the greatest moments of my life.
You were so beautiful.
You don't know how beautiful you are to me.
I mean just,
you're gorgeous,
you're precious.
It's a little much.
But it's been
to my mind when you said to me,
you want to go back with your ex boyfriend,
please erase him from your memory.
Don't ever go back in the past.
I know cause I've been there and I understand when you know that haircut and you
go on dates and not the compares to your racks,
but there is that better person out there and Julia,
I promise you it is me.
I will love you like you never been loved before.
Cherish shoe.
I'll make you feel like a woman,
a real woman,
and believe me,
after you experienced me,
you won't even know who your ex boyfriend is.
Open up your heart to me in your arms and you're on full throttle for the lack
of see me falling in love with you.
Go full throttle and just set it all.
I just looked in your eyes and I just melt
full travel.
And this is someone who just met.
Keep in mind,
I mean a day earlier or a day before,
the day before.
So she gave her his or she gave him her number?
I don't think so.
I mean it's not a normal guy like this.
Wouldn't do anything shady like pay to find out what
it does.
I'm sure she did it.
This story I hate,
I hate,
I don't want to spread misinformation because when we were about to get the full
story from her,
but uh,
somebody who said that they were friends with her said that he even discover her
name by the sign in sheet.
Yeah,
that's crazy.
How did this video get out though?
He sent it to her and she posted it.
No,
no.
You shared it with friends and then someone in that circle where it to share it
more?
No,
just send it to their friends.
It literally,
this went viral from Matt saying,
look,
look at,
I'm at the gym.
Yes.
And I got sent to us.
Well actually to be fair,
buzz feed,
I didn't know this at all because you know,
things get so big on the Internet so fast,
bigger than us.
You can,
you can latch onto something.
A couple of years.
This had a life on I think on buzzfeed a few years ago.
Oh,
years ago.
Like 2016 let's say.
And so,
but I mean,
you know,
it got some
notoriety and then it died down.
We discovered this,
I dunno,
a couple of months ago.
I mean,
you know,
it's new to us.
Has Anyone contacted this dude?
Well,
I don't know.
I mean,
I'm,
I now tell me this,
if you're like me,
because we've shown this to a couple of people now,
don't you feel like as a guy,
there's the part of your brain that identifies with what he's doing?
Like,
you know,
I feel embarrassment for him because I go,
you don't feel embarrassment for him.
Now I feel embarrassment for him.
I'm go,
I'm thinking about your question.
You know that like,
you've met someone who you're like,
I wish I could,
uh,
you know,
whatever.
Like you met someone,
you want to send them a message,
but your brain goes,
don't,
not this,
don't put out too much.
Like,
hold back,
like your own instincts tell you,
uh,
if don't go over the top of like,
Oh my God,
I love you because that's crazy to do.
And it's like,
he doesn't have that part that goes for him.
It's like,
just put it all out there,
opening up.
Your heart is going to love this.
She's going to just who I am.
Exactly.
That's what everybody loves about me.
That's why I live alone with three fucking ceiling fans.
Go back.
He's got two in the kitchen and some lighting.
He's got a lot of shit on the ceilings here.
This is my cute little hall.
I'll thank God everything.
I built everything,
every square ridge from crown mold into chair rail,
foursquare,
Ridge,
plumbing,
doors,
windows,
plumbing.
This is the type of guy.
Again,
I'm a very handy guy and uh,
I love to build you.
Whatever you want.
Add anything.
How about a future?
I hope this video doesn't scare you.
That's how it goes.
Everybody else's blog and I look forward.
I'm going out to dinner with you.
All right,
so let's make it happen.
Oh Chow.
But either with double negative on the sign off.
He knows he slipped on the diving board,
hit his head and fell in two of them on the way out of that dot.
Oh,
of course he's doing,
you know why?
Cause he ran this by a bunch of people first and all said,
don't fucking do it.
Like three,
three,
three guy friends.
He was like,
what do you guys know?
You're fucking single.
I'm sitting here talking to you idiots.
I'm doing it well.
I'm so happy I can show you this.
I have a lot more sympathy for him right now.
Why?
I just feel every time I see it I feel I feel worse and worse for him.
You know what I mean?
Like cause I get the impulse he's still single.
Yeah.
Cause like I see the desperation and wants so badly to have love and he just
doesn't know that you gotta be cool in the beginning.
Let's see.
That's the thing is he thinks that is cool.
Fine.
But here's the other thing again,
hang on.
Just want to say good morning.
I'm like,
this is her to her again.
Please say it's the next day.
My soon to be my everything
that now it's getting weird driving their truck.
Now it's getting,
the first video is excusable.
The second one when she doesn't respond is like,
oh she might've been
and that's how he's thinking right now.
How do you feel about this?
Oh Christ,
three months and then pretty high.
Wait,
is that really him?
Just sending guy.
I was going to say he got busted on college town and I met another girl,
Julia.
My name is Tricia.
Tricia.
Tricia is boyfriend,
big
Toronto.
It's a full break.
Julia,
what you need right now,
Julio full Bree took down all come and joy
everyday.
Julie fags down
in a garbage.
Julia.
I lost 73 pounds
guys killing it.
It's been there too.
It started to Yellow Cup
on the card.
Is that how he saw it to a cop?
Come over.
If I can shammy try out.
That's the one I know,
man.
It's so God damn funny.
Even just on Instagram,
the photo shops we've been getting have Garth Garth Brooks shit is,
I know someone in his team has had,
I'm a Garth Brooks fan.
Like legit.
I am a Garth.
Oh,
also I love shameless.
I love much too young to be this damn old.
I like those.
Garth.
Chris Gaines.
I don't dislike Chris game.
Are you serious?
No,
I dislike,
I don't like his alter ego,
but I do like his haircut.
That's cute.
Oh,
it looks good on Christine's after.
Let me,
I gotta get back.
But there's no way he hasn't heard this.
Something.
Can we address what quickly before we move along?
Is that the last time we recorded this show we were under threat.
Oh yeah.
We're just such a hassle
because it was a real panic.
Yeah.
Can we address that with the audience?
I feel like we just all over the place.
Sorry.
Yeah.
Sorry guys.
We've been recording this out of sequence.
That's why we just see now,
obviously we're back.
Everything's fine.
Uh,
it was,
it was a little bit of chaos for him.
It was a panic and we were terrible.
When we live,
we live fairly close to like the,
for instance,
uh,
an exit,
one exit past us,
two exits past us was shutdown and it was coming like the wind was moving it.
Where you officially an evacuation?
We had a voluntary,
so they were,
but they weren't like you have to,
but I mean this neighborhood basically emptied out,
you know?
Well,
and if you wait for them to tell you to go online and their babies,
we've got two young men and Tom Travels and so I was like,
let's just fucking go anyways.
So the amount of relief I saw on her face when I was like,
yeah,
let's just go.
She was like,
oh well there was raining down ashes and it was really smokey too.
Anyway,
we're back.
We're back.
We're fine,
everything's fine.
And thank you for all your kind tweets and your comments and stuff.
This is what's hilarious.
It's scary.
I was in that one right there in the canyon.
Where are you used to live?
Remember that one caught on fire on a year and we got the um,
it was like an amber alert style text on blast it on our phones.
It said you are officially on the line of evacuation.
You,
it's a voluntary one.
But if it creeps any farther south of like sunset,
then you have to go.
And it was ash everywhere and we got out.
It was scary.
That lady drew it looked like Armageddon going through there.
Joe's Joe's was mandatory.
And here's what's crazy.
Neighbors of his,
their house burned down.
It did.
[inaudible] and,
but he also had neighbors that stayed home.
And I'm like,
what?
I'm like,
if you're multiple houses are burning down.
And then he's like,
there's neighbors that were like,
yeah,
just sticking it out.
I didn't even tell you today.
I took our,
our tiny jeans to the doctor today for his four month.
Yeah.
Appointment driving,
driving up north.
I haven't driven,
it's all black.
Yeah.
Everything's burned up,
man and houses and everything's just gone.
It's,
it's fucking crazy.
It's like the apocalypse going north from here.
So really scary.
And it's exactly like two exits.
Anyways,
we're here.
So this is Garth Instagram.
I know I've been on it,
but I'm just showing you in it.
I feel like you open it.
Look at the comments.
Okay.
It's all trot off.
Yeah,
it's full throttle and he's all over the place.
Uh Oh really.
Thanks so much for you.
Here's my new fan page.
I'm sorry,
the uh,
g has you use going forward?
Let's get this.
Let's get physical plant music.
I liked that jeans up.
Um,
it's just been we've infiltrated.
Oh yeah.
Oh your sure you're away.
Come later for Moose suit.
That's the best part about our fans that they infiltrate.
Your fans are tell you,
your fans have been super supportive of me and my podcast and this album and I
still from time to time a mass defy eight elite,
uh,
Hillary Clinton's asshole.
Really?
I still get,
I swear to God,
I still good.
Yo,
did you really
look at this?
You will ask me that
Garth page.
Have you ever had the desire to call hung in and Philio stage and have a blast
of Fart in your face?
This is a Garth Brooks.
Ah,
lovely.
Could do with that either.
Now there's nothing.
They could do it as long.
There
he is.
Blast the Fart in your face.
So he's at the cons of the Trans Canada.
I want to get,
I mean you guys have taken over this page and I couldn't make me happier.
Nothing gives me joy.
Like this form means up.
Here you go.
It's a nice smile,
Garth.
I know that they're all saying it from here.
Nope,
Tom is,
they're asking me like,
do you want to sign up?
They're all like tagging me in all his shit now.
It's fucking,
I don't know.
I love it.
I love it too.
Let's do the,
yeah,
you're right.
Somebody like in his marketing teams,
like definitely there's someone paid and read that.
What if we could get Garth Brooks to call it on the show?
You know,
we got Gloria Stefan to conduct because of our bombardment on Twitter.
He's got her,
hey,
I don't kill people.
Like you got to say I do.
I Dunno.
Maybe we could start a campaign maybe.
What do you think?
I mean this is kind of its own campaign,
right?
Uh,
yeah.
I'm making this video that when you wake up this morning,
the trunk of my car,
because I just need you to know,
just like I fixed my house,
I fixed your water heater.
I'm going to fix you too.
And if you keep making noise back there,
I'm going to drive food.
Tridell
so funny.
Hey Julia Sealy mad store.
This guy with Laura
at that time it was a motley crew and got to sit front row in 1986 I want to
care for you.
I want to varnish you and keep you in my barn.
Never ever let go of you as you can sell my guy remodel a lot.
I have lots of ventilation in this whole place.
Just think you'll never think of your ex again for the rest of your life,
so come be with me Julia.
I would open up your heart to meet you.
Yeah,
open up your heart.
We're all open it up.
Yeah,
Rod,
all the way.
Love yet.
Got a sponsor.
He's got full throttle up with them.
Good afternoon Julie.
I just want to say one of the most beautiful times in my life,
hanging out with you last night.
We want to show you here what built it all myself
sand over here.
I put in the whole playground.
I planted the trees.
That's a kind of guy you're going to get and we will take you to dinner tomorrow
at Barney's.
Let's do it.
This called full throttle.
Andre
meet Joe.
I just wanted to say that that conversation that we had the other night was the
best 23 minutes of my life.
From then on,
I knew that you and I were meant to be together.
I could see myself bringing your around when I'm with the boys,
maybe introducing you to the seventh floor crew that you see this light.
I started myself sometimes when I sit and stare at it for hours on end,
it just reminds me of me and you'll turned on and lights up my life.
Oh God.
Let you make the distinction of whose hope he does a great goal.
Fresh.
Oh my God.
Julia,
meet Joe.
Just wanted to say hi.
Wish you a great day and uh,
just want to let you know that meeting you yesterday and getting to look at you
first of all.
And it looks like it is five 30.
I yeah.
Like it looks like he's literally doing this at the morning is right.
Oh Gosh.
She's just been sending my mind brake lights lighten up his face actually,
friend.
Just to race.
And from your memory.
You never gonna see him again.
He's in my trunk is dead type of guy again.
Love that.
That's my favorite
fan.
Here's Matthew.
Oh my God.
In jewel.
Check in on your hope.
You're having a great day.
[inaudible] just wanted to say kind of looks like you last night was one of the
best days of my life is so beautiful Julia.
And uh,
any talks or getting back with your ex,
just uh,
put that out of your head.
You can forget he ever existed
up in a black hefty bags in my garage,
a garage.
I built myself.
Everything from the crown molding to the flows and Nice,
let's do this
thing.
Uh,
you know,
please ignore the pictures of my wedding day or anything has to do with my wife
cause our,
I'll fucking kill.
Oh God.
These are getting better.
I love our audience so much for these.
I know it starts as a seed and then it grows.
But also the guy in the fan stores in a public place doing that.
I mean like a manager could walk by and look the fuck are you doing buddy?
It's so good.
Crown mold,
mold grows up,
but the life that this had on buzzfeed,
it didn't have this line.
No,
no,
there's been no Paul's for two years and all of a sudden you all just fucking
Frankenstein all of augur.
Well that's why she reached out.
She was just like,
Hey,
I thought this was,
you're like,
hi Julie.
Uh,
she seems so nice.
She seems that's why he probably fell for all these guys.
Love what happened.
I'll tell you what happened.
I bet you he says that when she was,
and she's like one of those sincere nice people who was like hi and made eye
contact and saw him and was like smiled and he was like,
this is my wife right here.
I'm going to make this lady,
my wife.
She just paid attention to me,
like really gave a normal mistake.
I'm going to make sure I clarify that normal mistake would be like,
cause I made that mistake too when someone's been overly friendly and I'm like,
hmm.
Yeah.
But as far as I'll go is to offer my number.
I don't ever ask for,
there's,
I'll give mine,
if you want to call you call.
If you don't,
I,
you know,
you're going to get the fucking point.
You don't,
if she never calls,
you don't fucking send videos.
You know what I'm saying?
Like the normal,
I think,
again,
it's a mistake.
That's a lot of times I go with a waitress,
especially their job is to be flurries and you know,
be overly friendly and touchy and all that Shit.
Yeah.
We have a friend that used to go there quite a lot.
Or Hooters.
Yeah.
Three of them.
He was very close to you,
do I to live with you?
Oh yeah.
He was a regular,
he was,
he had a table wait,
taught him and he had regular titty was,
uh,
he was the guy and there's guys like this who at who?
Like I'm the type of person who,
uh,
resents the overly friendly waitress in a place,
like where I know their coach to do it.
I'm like,
I stopped smiling because I feel like it's so contrived.
You know what I mean?
Exactly.
So like when they're like hope yet and then the smiley face on the thing and I'm
like,
all right,
like I'm not,
I'm not a sucker.
Like stop.
Well the Hooters girl and that's what I'm saying,
fucking treat you like a side.
He's the guy,
our friend is the guy who's like,
I think that check really liked he's captain Cevallo.
That's who you like that she's trained to do that.
And he's like,
no,
no.
She put her hand on my arm and she told me if I was,
she's like,
you look happy today or you look sad today.
I was going to cheer you up.
I'm like,
that's all coached.
You don't know that.
That's cool.
That's a question.
Now hold on.
So this mutual friend,
cause that seems to me to be the guy that's prone to making the good morning
Julia videos.
It's a guide.
I misread the sign.
So did this guy kind of overstep the corny
multiple times?
Uh,
so many times.
I don't know how the,
I don't know how much I should say to be honest,
because,
you know,
uh,
but,
yes,
he,
um,
well I'll tell this story.
There was one time where he went into the back of,
um,
la weekly and found them a Seuss and then he hit me up,
but he's like,
[inaudible] a sous coming over tonight.
I'm like,
Oh yeah,
my neck and back have been bothering me.
I'm like a house house.
Massoud Song Makes House calls.
Yeah.
Sophia here the door.
Just,
you know,
let her in.
I'm like,
okay.
And then she knocks on the door and I opened it up and,
and she's like,
hi.
And I'm like,
are you the misuse?
And she's like,
yeah.
And I'm like,
where's your table?
Where's your chair?
Where's your oil?
Where's your tat you got,
you don't even have a fanny pack on?
Like I've had massage and,
uh,
she's like,
oh,
he's like,
stop stops.
So He lets a pea lesser in,
he lets her head and he uh,
you know,
spends a few hours and then she leaves and I'm no,
no,
that's right.
Thank you.
She doesn't leave.
She uh,
he sends her into my room to take a shower.
So I,
I had left,
I come back and I'm like,
Hey,
who's in my shower?
He said call the Mizzou.
So I'm like,
what the fuck?
I go,
dude,
that's basically a prostitute.
Okay.
No,
she's nice.
I go,
there's a lot of nice prostitutes.
but my wallet and Shit or like,
what are you doing?
That's my room.
Like personalized.
Couldn't she had a bathroom?
What?
Cause he didn't want her dirty ass in there,
you know?
So I go,
Hey,
I'm beating on my door.
Like,
Yo,
you gotta wrap that shit up and get out,
get out,
got to get out of my bathroom.
And he's like,
don't be like that to her.
I'm like,
he's like,
she's not like that.
I get you just spent an hour and a half with this woman in your room getting a
massage.
What do you mean you don't know a fucking thing about her?
So I do a show on it.
This is back in the Ontario days when you would drive out and back and out and
back.
And on that Saturday night,
remember you did an 11 o'clock show and I was middling.
So I don't,
I'm not getting home until one 32 o'clock you know,
and I'm always on an adrenaline high.
Can't fall asleep right away.
So I'm watching some TV and it's about three 30 in the morning at this point.
And I see this bedroom light turn on and I hear two voices.
I'm like,
oh well go for him.
He fucking,
he got laid and the door opens up and here comes the Massoud.
I go,
yeah,
now I go,
what the fuck are you doing?
Well,
I go,
how much did that cost you right now?
How she didn't charge me?
I go,
Bull Shit.
She just wants to get to know me.
That's it.
So does the Yup.
Paid a fuckload.
Okay.
I was at a strip club with him one night.
That's wait,
wait.
But he didn't pay her weight.
So you found out that Romans not coming over for fighters that better one,
the Strip club,
the Strip club one was going to a strip club.
Multiple makes it like,
are you going back to the Strip club?
Yeah.
And then he's like,
I like it.
It's,
it sounds like a good morning Julia
thing where Ryan's like how much money have you spent at the Strip club?
And he's like,
in the last couple of days,
yeah,
that's what,
he had a,
if you have to ask him if there was a clarifier,
$800.
Oh my God.
And then
he was like beat,
beat,
beat.
But this girl really likes it.
Oh No.
Really?
100%.
I went a couple times with them
and um,
uh,
he's like,
I'm going to go in the back with this girl.
I'm like,
okay.
And you just go get a,
you know,
you got to get a lap dance or whatever,
but those girls are fucking be straight up with you.
Like for a couple of bucks,
you know,
we can work some shit out.
So he was gone.
I mean,
it was a while.
And then finally I was like,
well fuck this.
I want it.
This is how long he was gone.
He was gone for like 30 minutes and I was just sitting in a strip club by
myself,
which I always think is creepy.
Anyway,
so I'm like,
well fuck,
I got a joint in the car.
So I go out to the parking lot.
I smoke an entire join by myself.
Okay.
I'm out there for a good 2030 minutes.
I go back in,
he's still not back.
And then when he finally does show up like another 30 minutes later,
he comes from behind me and I know that's where the ATM is.
And I go,
what the fuck,
man?
I said,
I thought maybe you crossed the line and they were back there fucking you up.
I didn't know,
but I can't get back there.
I didn't know what was going on and hear from you.
Well,
here's what happened.
She likes,
she likes me.
No,
he said that he can't come from head.
So he's paying for a blow job,
but he can't tell her,
hey,
this doesn't really work on me.
So he's being overly polite letting her do this,
cause he doesn't want to stop her.
What he forgets is that you also have,
you're paying for the dance per song,
right.
He's back there for like six fucking songs more.
So he's paying the dance plus fees for drove?
Yeah.
Why is he
just Jag?
I Dunno.
Let's see.
I'm looking into it.
So we should ask them.
Hey,
can we pull up his,
that's what it was.
It was like,
it was like a $1,200 a night.
Oh my God.
You got about the fucking,
I have my God,
why is it told me?
I don't know if there's somebody,
we all know.
Somebody told me a story about 1200 years being at a strip club.
I gotta be a stripper.
I know.
Being a strip.
No.
And talking to somebody like talking to the girl.
He just like,
I'm here.
You're there.
Yeah.
And he was just like,
it just went on and on.
Just kept talking.
And then after 20 or 30 minutes he was like,
all right,
you know it's going to go over here now talk to somebody else.
And they're like,
Whoa,
whoa girls like you owe me like 600 bucks.
Cause that was like six songs.
And he was like,
he was like,
I didn't know
talking to her for her time,
she was saying that it was that he was talking to her in an area called the boy.
He was in the bullpen.
He was in the boat.
If you talked to her over there,
it's all right.
It's up to her.
It's up to her eyes over here and that means you're wow.
He got like,
you know,
then they security can cause I'm not paying you fucking die.
I,
it's not fair.
If you're not made aware of that policy beforehand,
is it?
I mean,
well of course not.
Yeah.
If it's a range then it's a rain.
She should tell him,
hey dude,
you do you mind?
This is what the deal is.
This is the money seat.
Yeah.
Bikes.
So that's,
he would have conversation.
He got to know all their real names.
All their real names,
which by the way,
isn't their real name?
They've got three.
I'm Tyson.
Okay.
What's your real name?
Chanel.
It's probably Jennifer.
Right.
You know what I mean?
It's none of those.
And he would tell them all the time,
his line was,
you're better than this.
He would say that to these girls.
And they were like,
no,
I'm not.
I'm making a ton of fucking money.
Right.
I want to do this.
He wants to save everyone.
This is a perfect,
yeah.
Time to say I,
I got a message,
uh,
this week from the a stripper,
the emailed.
Hey Tom,
I'm a huge fan of yours at Christina's.
I'm a stripper.
I really love your comments on these weird try it out type guys.
I have a story for you guys.
This past weekend I had a customer come in who is really into castration,
um,
and I was wearing a plaid outfit.
I guess this will make sense.
He ended up getting a lap dance.
Uh,
but elap dance is not what he wanted.
He laid on the floor in the lab room and the lap dance room asked me to stomp on
his balls with my sharp stripper heels.
Great Wild role playing as a farm girl who's going to castrate her least
favorite bowl.
Okay.
I wish I had a video of this conference.
That sounds amazing.
It so I love that,
by the way.
Good for her.
See that's,
but that's why it's good to be a stripper.
He didn't,
she didn't have to have sex with him,
right?
She said,
no,
she's,
she's great.
Stomped on his nuts.
That's what I'm always saying is like the fart videos,
the nut crushing stuff.
That's easy money.
That's money on the table if
you're a woman and not doing those things.
Now let's talk about the psychology behind the guy that does the good morning
Julia and,
and the $1,200 a stripper.
What's going on with him?
You,
you started to say a little bit that you think it's the,
he wants to rescue these.
Yeah,
he feels,
I think that makes him feel good.
You know what I mean?
Like,
but here's the other thing,
it's,
it's complex because after that night,
after he was in the back,
that was the first time he'd been with someone.
He got in the car and he just took a deep breath and he looked at me,
he started getting them [inaudible].
He's like,
I think she was a prostitute.
I said,
she gave her money for a sexual favor.
Like she's a prostitute.
That's the definite,
and he was upset with himself.
He was,
because he felt he was better than that.
You're not.
You see what I'm saying?
Like now he's putting it off like,
no,
I,
I'm better than that.
I can,
um,
I'm now one of those people.
I'm like,
they're the people you shit on all the time.
That's who you are.
You know?
I really do think that that particular person we're talking about,
and this guy too,
he wants a,
here's what he's saying.
Look,
look at all I can do.
I can provide for you.
I can take care of you.
I can protect you.
I can love you like no one else ever has.
And I know that because we,
I saw your name on a cup.
I'm like,
you give a dental update gene.
Um,
I've actually been doing all right,
hang on,
let me see.
No,
I think theory a little yellowy yet.
Have you been,
I'm rushing.
Um,
yeah,
I've been brushing,
I'll tell you dental update for two year old.
I took him to the dentist last time and uh,
and the lady goes,
you need to see the dentist goes,
you need to start flossing.
I go flossing my two year old.
She goes,
yeah.
I go,
well how do you suggest I do that?
She goes,
well,
I hold my son down.
I just hold him down and he screams and I just go ahead and floss as he screams.
I'm like,
I'm pretty sure that's not the way it's the way to do it.
Your children at first dentist visit was horrific.
Relayed in like the tax lap.
He was like,
ah,
need to shoot.
But our dentist office has,
um,
it's how he found a movie.
Trolls.
I'd never seen it before.
They lay the chair back and they put us a TV on the ceiling.
The kids can watch them felt we could do it now.
Yeah.
And uh,
yeah,
that was,
she was not having that either,
by the way.
Yeah.
How are your teeth?
I mean,
I've been to cal Ripken have good teeth for years and years.
Guys.
I've had my thi let me say it.
Yeah,
they're nice.
I to get my first give now look,
there was a lot of work done to them,
but I didn't get my first cavity until I'm 45 42 Gotcha.
You're 45 yup.
Parts like six years older than you.
Kreischer yeah,
he looks it.
Yeah.
You're like 15 or in all of it coming up on 60 play.
Do you think I look like,
oh,
see guy or show low with my flannel.
Christina's me now I saw the,
I saw your shirts the other day was kind of fucked up.
I'm going to go,
oh,
see guy a black on black truck with blacked out windows.
Yes.
Yeah.
Like a raptor.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Like a Ford Raptor at Tahoe Tahoe,
one of those desert trucks that you can tell your motorcycles out.
Yeah.
One of those guys,
he goes to the Salton Sea,
come over for the Q dog.
He probably got really long shorts and socks.
You probably got this much skin showing on your leg.
You know,
you drink a lot of like energy drinks and shit.
Hold on.
I want to bring up one thing before we go forwards.
This is kind of a big draw.
Our dear friend,
you know him,
Eric Lundy.
Remember this guy used to write cartoons with back.
He and I used to work writing children's stuff together for years.
Anyways,
he moved back to Kansas City for the last few years.
Has been working on a comic called hollow leg and he spent years.
It's crazy.
I've dedicated this guy is to this.
I mean I'm serious.
The level of the time and commitment and the artistic craft building.
Um,
a,
an uh,
a comic book catalog.
Oh,
he has an enormous,
he's a fantastic artist.
He's just hit me up today.
Artists.
This would be the equivalent.
Literally if you have you been like,
you know I have them stand up for years and you're like,
yeah.
He'd be like,
well I never said anything until now,
but um,
I have 19 albums.
Right.
Literally Serious Id box it,
it's that much he has built,
if you go check out his thing,
you're not going to see like,
oh this is cool picture.
Maybe I'll give him a shot.
He actually has the content ready to go.
It's amazing.
Yeah.
He sent me stuff over the years.
I love his thoughts and here's the best part about Eric.
He was a stand up comic.
He comes from our world.
He's a fantastic writer and he taught himself how to draw.
It's unreal.
Oh I didn't know that.
Self taught and he did it all in the last few years and he's been working and
working.
Anyways,
he's finally launched his brand new APP and I really,
I encourage you all to try it out,
check it out.
He's also a mommy.
He listens to this show.
So Hey Eric,
shout out to the lender pants.
It's called hollow leg comics.com.
Right?
Hollow leg comics.
He's on Twitter,
hollow leg comics,
Instagram.
And you can download the APP on iTunes right now.
So check it out.
Hollow leg comics.com.
Shout out to Eric London.
Congrats.
And he just got a dog.
Yeah,
he just got it off.
I should plug the sale.
It's the holiday sale.
It's Thanksgiving week,
black Friday.
Here it is.
Here's the on some of the online stuff.
It's coming for this year.
It's already moving.
Um,
this will,
the first item will definitely sell out by the weekend.
So Jesus wore jeans is our holiday sweater,
Jesus' word,
jeans,
t shirt.
There's a stocking and ornament.
And then there's Santa Claus stuff,
Christmas stuff.
And then we move into Christina's new ride or die stuff.
The piss on me shirt a home here.
Now try it out.
It's just all there.
So here's the deal.
If you want 15% off,
use the code.
Tom F,
R I,
Tom,
like for Friday,
uh,
at checkout.
That's merchant method.com/tom Segura and it's all there now and the Christmas
sales going.
And this year we're going to be supporting a starlight children's foundation as
our chair.
The uh,
right.
Uh,
that's good.
We think of this gene.
Watch this,
this person
on the plane
guy looking around.
I mean,
I mean seriously.
Isn't that unbelievable?
Look at that.
Look at this dude.
Look,
this dude toss,
uh,
his look around.
This is my favorite part of this.
He's like
this guy right here
in this shit,
man.
Nasty.
Oh,
she's pushing on her vagina particles and particles throughout the plane.
It's not okay.
Isn't that people do nasty shit.
Nasty Shit.
Yeah.
Bare feet always freak out when you find it here.
When they put it on your fucking serious.
Yeah.
I've seen a lot of people texting shit,
pick their feet,
picked up diapers now special that I'm a parent.
I look for that shit.
I seen diapers rolled up,
just left on to seat and when they get out of the plane,
I'm like,
you fucking pig.
Just feels hell.
A Red table.
Talk family back in Baltimore.
It's going to be a difficult,
sensitive topic.
We are going to be talking about race and racial relations between women and
ain't gon be easy.
No,
cause you and I've already had some conversations that we've gotten pretty tight
about.
Yeah.
I'm really talking about all that biases because the sad part is,
is that I realize I've got some serious prejudices and biases myself.
So there's a racial divide between women of color and white women.
We don't talk about it much,
but it's real and it's deep.
Any comment about race?
No matter how well intentioned can set off a firestorm,
which scares people away from even talking about the issue.
Now,
one about this Ms. Dean that really breaks my heart is that white women
understand what it feels to be oppressed because what it feels to exactly
because of their sex,
what it feels to be ostracized or not being treated as an equal.
Right.
You know what?
I found this,
this quote,
I'm gonna read it.
Prejudice is the emotional commitment to ignorance.
Hmm.
Well,
I have to admit I'm guilty because I do have my own biases,
specifically with blonde women.
Blonde hair on white women just triggers me
blonde hair.
She has blonde hair.
I know both those ladies have blocked her mom.
Her mom looks damn good.
So
that's why she cleared it up cause she goes blown with and her mom was like,
Huh,
okay.
Is that dude nine old biases specifically with blonde women?
Blonde hair on white women just triggers me.
Okay.
Yeah.
I knew I had something special with Jadah.
I knew it.
Yeah.
She and I would be natural enemies apparently.
I guess so.
Damn.
You know,
and I've had a specific incident with someone who has blonde hair.
Absolutely.
All throughout my childhood I do remember experiencing being teased by white
women in regards to my hair,
how I looked and I feeling belittled.
I think it's always interesting though,
when someone's like the way I looked and there literally like a perfect looking
human being.
She's gorgeous.
Gorgeous.
Yes.
She's fallen
face.
Okay.
Well,
I mean I believe her,
but she hates Wiley's blip,
blonde hair.
She was like,
you know,
I hate like I get triggered by it.
White women with blonde hair,
Christina P,
other people.
She just said,
I hate her so much.
I love that there is a love to like if someone that big hate you,
you got to support that.
Are you kidding me?
That'd be awesome.
Thank you for the fact that you enough that you hate me.
I didn't realize.
Hmm.
Um,
yeah.
Yeah.
We have a prank call that came in from Fort Simpson.
Cool.
I love that.
This might've been Halloween one.
Thank you for calling.
How can I help you?
Well,
names.
Hello.
How are you?
Oh,
just moved into this house but two weeks ago there's been a lot of weird things
happen.
This is how I moved into this place.
I've been talking with different people around town.
They've been told me about different ghosts in this house.
Are you trying to get rid of those like spirits in your house?
They told me about this woman that used to kill Moose or something,
mark it and then make soup on level.
Okay.
Litter was also a guy that used to let strangers sexually abusive,
so they live in his house.
Um,
awesome.
Heard about a guy that used to smoke meth with his brother,
labeled do sick and disgusting things.
The
Chinese shut up told me this Asian massage therapist
like committed suicide in the house.
Something like that.
Okay.
Have you seen her?
What kinds of things have you heard?
Just a cabinet doors come open.
Things fall out the covers.
Okay.
Um,
yeah.
Whole.
Someone locked you slump.
We'll need your help.
Help me some of these spirits right now.
Okay.
Fair to say.
Taneka Fotay tous in cure.
CEO Sick die.
Balaka Humana's creek.
Doris,
can you hear me?
Yes.
Paired conus.
Ruff.
Yeah.
No,
they're a
great,
right.
Bitter.
It's are you with us asking if you can live in peace spirits?
Are you here to harm us in any way?
Ghost.
Can you hear me
all day?
Census.
Do what?
Say that again.
Oh.
Starting to feel Saltman side down.
Whoa.
What's going on?
Get it now.
I feel like something's inside me now.
Feel all this hate.
Oh,
if you're able to Amazon
or to leave the home.
Hell.
Hell her.
Me.
Mommy.
Hey.
Hell
yeah.
Yeah.
Hi.
The tides.
Jesus.
What the hell?
Just happened.
What just happened?
I just woke up covered mile feces.
Mione Yoren
but it sounds like they were,
they were definitely in your house.
I'm scared.
I just want to live in this house.
Say something.
My answer me now.
Well I don't hear anything.
Alright.
We're all guessing.
It looks like these spirits are here to stay.
I appreciate all your help.
Everything you done for me or I'm going to go wash my shitty drawers.
Yeah,
absolutely.
Absolutely.
All right.
Pre Halloween mommies.
Yeah,
you got it.
Bart Simpson.
Thanks so much for that.
Very good world.
Done Far Simpson.
Yeah,
always good.
Oh my God.
Um,
last thing I wanted to show you because Christina was really into this.
Do you like that?
Jane is upset with me.
She hates you.
I hate that.
I love her so much.
And I,
I watch red table talk on Facebook.
I don't know if you've seen it.
I do.
I'm a giant pink Pinkett Smith Fan.
Oh my God,
it's so good.
They talk about everything to just worry about being Jadah.
I know.
That's really weird.
Oh my God.
Hello?
Oh,
when you fall and cannot get a
tragic at Eric
and I can't get up these days.
Yeah.
Terror.
So we were in a hotel room,
was it during the evacuation?
Ab and we were watching television and this comes on and I'm like,
oh my God.
That's the most horrifying thing I've ever seen.
Like the whole cheesy,
I fallen.
I can't get up as an enough now.
It's horrifying now.
Now you're putting an image in,
in,
in children's heads of their older parents who are home alone.
So dark.
Oh my God.
That was terrifying.
Yeah,
it's going to die.
He's down there.
I mean the price low,
like the slow build and you're like,
what is,
this is terrifying.
I don't know what,
you know what?
I didn't know what the fuck are you guys are about to show me.
And this is the,
this is a legit thing.
Yeah,
it's real.
This is where grandma lives.
I know grandma.
Yeah,
she's down there weeping a lot.
Oddly.
Slip and falls.
We all know.
You know what I'm saying?
Grandma got from scratch,
which might be gaining the system.
Ah,
look at this.
It's a nice tube,
two story house and then she's down there crying down.
[inaudible] sweet Nana.
No,
I thought she was face down too,
but I see it now.
She's faced.
Yeah,
I at first time I saw it I was like man,
but see her nose and mouth.
Yeah,
no,
she can breathe them screen.
Yeah.
She's like,
look,
if you guys are going to let have me lay here 10 hours on Monday,
I don't remember.
I think it was dumb bitch though.
She was carrying your laundry and then her ship fell.
Maybe she didn't carry that along.
Great.
And right off to the side here,
somebody is going to be like,
Eh,
we got it Linda.
We got it now.
You're right.
Okay.
You want it.
Can I tell you about a gaming,
the Sizzler,
good game in the system.
Not just learned in Baltimore.
I was there and this is,
I'm proud and not proud at the same time.
Yeah.
So the racket that I haven't seen here with these limes scooters and these birds
scooters in Baltimore city is these inner city kids when you're just out there
toward Harvard Shit,
they run up to it,
he push you off of it and then they take it because it's on your dime and
however much,
oh my God,
maybe it was ride it until this shit runs out.
And then you know where they throw him in the harbor.
So they had to start taking them away.
Cause if don't them in the harbor.
Oh my God.
So there's a bike share program.
Um,
and Baltimore city is the only city in the world that partakes in this bike
share program that doesn't want to share the fog and bikes.
They stole every bike.
Okay.
They're all gone.
So they created something,
again,
it's called the Baltimore Lock.
It's the only city in the world doing this and that didn't work.
And now the bike share program,
it's gone because the bikes are gone.
Oh by God,
volleyball
or hustling down there.
Man,
I got something.
I keep coughing.
I got aids and maybe do something.
Um,
sickle cell,
you're going to be working with us pretty soon,
man.
We're going to be,
we're working on this project with a new studio and we'll be putting out
podcasts and years going to be one of them is first of all,
thank you for having me.
I'm starting to be a part of your,
uh,
can we,
can we talk about it full on like your network is,
am I allowed to say that?
I don't know what it's called.
I just know we're gonna be producing podcasts and trying to put out content.
Glad to be under the umbrella play.
It'd be fun.
I'm stoked for it.
I really am.
The girl,
by the way,
we'll know is just that like you'll sign on,
you know,
whatever you subscribe to podcasts.
But also on our video channel you just have like a full new show or you know,
we'll try to get you something five days a week,
you know,
so it's not us five days a week.
No,
no.
Just something that like is,
you know,
related days,
Ryan show and then we'll have,
we have a few other people that we think will be a nice fit as a companion to
your mom's house.
So the whole idea is it's people that we know that this audience responds to
people.
It's not people who you know at,
you know everyone likes cause everyone doesn't like everyone,
but it's people who,
the majority of people were always like,
yeah,
we,
we like this person.
Well,
I'm excited to have video.
Like I'm excited to have video.
Uh,
you know,
I want to take it,
I want to do a lot of stuff.
I have some ideas for patrion awesome.
I want that shit down.
I'm excited to do some stuff with you guys.
It's going to be fun,
man.
Everybody knows the mommy's listening and watching.
We're not going to change our show,
so don't worry.
Your mom's house is going to stay exactly the same except we're going to upgrade
the studio a little bit.
You'll see some cooler shit,
some slick stuff,
some neat stuff,
some real raw stuff too.
[inaudible]
right.
We got to go full trial.
We're gonna get physical with with music,
so that's going to be nice.
Yeah.
Physical podcasts and physical comedy.
You got to do it.
Get physical with podcast.
Fucking Provo.
You got to do that.
Let's find Phillips.
Give,
let's get physical doing podcasts.
I like that
you're smiling.
Genuinely you need to do,
do look like him though.
Honest to God people when they Photoshop it,
I have to look three or four times like,
is this really like,
I'm like,
is that just like you kind of look like Doris BrooksBrooks' Bro,
don't let,
don't really smile.
Like make your eyes not matched your mouth.
That's how he
smiles Garth,
but bigger
that it matches.
Yeah.
The one that I didn't post,
I didn't repose,
but this one I was like,
whew.
The Photoshop.
It looks like it was too easy.
That's what I'm saying,
man.
Just lay it right in there.
Yeah,
just put a hat on top.
I put in and out.
He's got blue eyes in the same coloring is you I think,
right?
He does those really pretty blue eyes.
They're probably Photoshop.
Tom's aren't.
No,
it's already buried.
Oh,
here it is.
I mean,
Shit.
I'm just like,
oh,
it's so ridiculous.
It says let's get physical Nicholas
talented Photoshop or you got some,
you got some bees out there.
All right.
The new album,
it's um,
what's it called?
Get Ahold of your
iTunes,
Amazon,
Google play,
Spotify,
Pandora.
Everywhere you get it.
Sicklers the best.
Support the album.
Please get it.
And I'm number one on iTunes right now.
Sorry for the quick,
abrupt segue.
I forgot to do it live,
so I'm doing it now.
We're going to jump over to our conversation with Sean Anders,
the writer,
director of instant family.
It's a great time.
I'm sorry.
Here's that.
So excited and thrilled that this worked out.
It is holiday week.
Obviously it's Thanksgiving week and I can actually say that yours truly is in a
movie that is playing in theaters right now.
You can take your family,
take them today,
tomorrow,
all weekend long to see instant family and we're being joined by the writer,
director,
producer,
Mr Sean Anders.
I just realized my chair is sinking now.
God,
why don't you do some weight?
Jesus.
We haven't had somebody waste so much that sits here before.
Oh,
Bert,
Bert.
Well Bro,
bro,
Bro,
thanks for coming over.
First of all,
thanks for having me here.
Thanks for making actually,
you know,
I know this feels hokey and sincere.
Uh,
but I,
you actually made a dream of mine come true by putting me in a movie.
Wow.
So,
and I almost,
I don't want to get too emotional.
I'm going to remove eye contact.
Um,
no,
but you know,
when I moved out here,
the honest to God truth is I never had any aspirations whatsoever to do standup.
I didn't come out of here with that idea of my whole thing was like,
I just want to act and I wanted to act in movies,
not television.
I love movies and I thought I would be a comedic actor.
That's,
that's really what I thought I would do.
I went to the Groundlings,
I did some shows with second city,
uh,
groups like,
you know,
sketch shows.
And I was like,
you know,
I booked a couple of commercials.
I was like,
oh,
this is like a natural progression.
I'll be an actor and I,
you know,
I fell into stand up and I started to work as a standup and then that went that
way.
But man de last fit sounds crazy,
15,
years.
I was always like,
man,
fucking sucks.
And then as specialists came out,
I'd be like,
there's no one fucking director that could watch something that I'm in and be
like,
he could play apart.
It turns out that was and a so thank you so much for giving me the opportunity
man.
Well,
no man,
thank you.
You,
you killed it.
And uh,
and it's funny because my,
the way I got started,
I was kind of the opposite.
I loved movies,
but I never thought in a million years that I'd have a shot at doing this kind
of stuff.
So me and my friends just made a movie just purely just for fun and just to have
a good time and just to see if we could do it.
And it turned into this nonsense,
you know?
So you have a fucking crazy career now.
I,
what did you first make tell us that we made this movie.
It's called NBT never been thawed and it was a mockumentary because that's what
you do and you don't have any money and you want to make a comedy.
And it was about a group of people that collect frozen entrees and they're
trying to put on the first frozen entree enthusiasts convention.
And it was just kind of about subculture and nonsense.
And we just did it purely for fun and it,
and it Kinda of juice.
I should not have said anything.
That's me.
Yeah.
I know.
It's so interesting about people who take in their lives is that there was a
time when you were just this kid in Wisconsin who was like,
I'd love to direct movies Sunday and we just made this thing and then this
happens and so done by the way.
So incredibly dumb.
Like just so just painfully dumb.
And uh,
I don't know how that's how you describe yourself.
I say to lead though,
we were just talking about Isabella right before we started about Isabella
Manayer who plays at Lizzie and the movie and she's just crazy talented,
this kid.
It's also,
it's funny you say that though.
We were talking about how talented she is and what a career she has going.
The other thing is like when you talked to her,
a couple of things that come through like in my experience was that like a um,
w superintelligent yeah.
Um,
and like it doesn't conduct,
like when I talked to her on the set,
I don't feel like I'm talking to like a teenager.
Right.
You know,
you kind of feel like you're talking to an adult and I'm sure that contributes
to confidence and success as a 16 year old.
And you know,
because a,
that's not the way most teenagers conduct himself.
But that's what I mean is that when I was that age,
I don't think I could barely even put a sentence together.
And actually she inspired me being around her.
I started bringing my kids to work more often,
bringing them to the edit bay and stuff.
Cause I thought I need to just,
I need you to make sure that my kids are around grownups enough to just get that
confidence to be able to just,
you know,
when the grownups come up and say,
Hey,
what's your name and not go through.
Yeah.
You always have this thing.
This is before we even had kids where you always noted when we walk into like an
elevator or something,
you're like the,
like you'd say hello to a kid and you're like,
I'm still just say hello.
Yeah,
hello to somebody.
Which I was always like,
oh,
okay.
Because he's sumption is when you're a child,
that adults,
because they're older than you know everything or they know better than you and
then you become an adult in your life.
These dumb motherfuckers,
these people are dumber than me.
Why are you talking about so that and also having the audacity to dream big and
to do the thing you want to do.
It's so important.
You know?
I could never do that.
Like you,
of course you can.
Yeah.
About,
about going just doing it.
But I do talk about how dreaming big is like so important and,
and not letting people,
you know,
cause a lot of the time do you say like something like I want to make a movie
and they're like,
yeah,
you fucking,
you know,
people are like,
come on man.
People really say that a lot more people say that.
Then the other way,
you know,
well you were saying that your father was a mailman and your family is pretty,
they're working.
My Dad was a forklift mechanic and I think to,
the thought of being in show business was like,
I may as well have told him I wanted to go to the moon and live there.
It was like,
why would you even,
were they supportive of you or they were supportive but the kind of like what
Tom said,
my dad grew up very poor,
so it was all about you gotta Punch in,
you got to get a steady paycheck,
all that kind of stuff.
I always wanted to do kind of what I wanted to do and,
but my parents were always really supportive of whatever cause they never had
that thought of like,
I think they knew from an early age,
he's not,
this guy's not running for Senate,
you know,
so they're,
whatever,
whatever makes you happy.
But you know,
I have to say though your,
your attitude about all of that,
it's really special being onset and having people around.
And we had a lot of them on this movie who even people like,
like Julia Haggardy as an example,
who's spending like a thousand movies and has been doing it forever and still
has this glee about the process and about being there.
And whenever you have people around that are just like excited to be there,
it makes it so much.
That was really something cool about it.
Tom would come home and be like,
I love everybody.
I love everybody on this movie.
Everybody's nice,
everybody's turning into an actor.
I'm like,
Oh,
you got to meet all the other actors.
Such great people.
It's infectious.
But it also wasn't a,
you know,
for lack of a better word,
it wasn't like an actor.
He kind of vibe around there at all.
Like everybody was just really,
really cool.
Michael O'keefe,
100% thought I was a studio executive or if he came up cause I was wearing the
leather Russ leather jackets everybody all day we talk about like is that your
jacket?
And I was like,
it's just fucking jackets were inspired by my brother Ben.
Well he's got a little,
he's got a little Bob mixed in there a little bit,
but these people would come up and they're like shy.
But Mike goes,
thanks so much.
And I was like,
for what this is like right when I meet him and he's like,
it was just excited to be here and I turned to John Your writing partner and I
was like,
he just thanked me for this job and I was like,
no problem man.
It's look like a day from the figure out that I'm in it.
Yeah.
Well,
I look,
I look like
a douchey producer on our park day cause I had my,
my leather thing with the stripes and sung.
It's like a Hollywood dick.
Can I tell you the best part about seeing,
we saw the screening of instant family.
I think we,
I just given birth to Julian like a week before and we went to go see it and it
was so stunning to see my husband.
Oh,
I'm like the big screen and your beard was darker.
They took the gray out and your outfits were so funny.
I'm like,
Oh my God,
this guy's such a d bag.
Put you in this Douche bag.
It was so funny.
It was so good
fun.
Uh,
dressing in things you wouldn't normally dress like,
you know what I mean?
And embracing them.
That actually is probably one of the most perfect for the care.
That's one of the things about acting though is like,
you know,
doing things like changing your hair,
changing your clothes and then do you remember what we did to you with that
double tap?
Double.
Remember there,
there was the day that the double showed up because you weren't going to be able
to be,
there was a,
there was a shot.
It didn't end up in the movie because honestly the devil was too far off.
You remember?
You don't remember this.
So this guy,
this guy shows up who's going to be the Segora from behind double cause we were
just going to get a shot.
Now we're going to get a shot of,
of Tom and Allen walking toward the house on a day when Tom wasn't gonna be able
to be at that sat.
And the guy came up to just kind of like get his wardrobe approved and you were
going like,
what?
I don't look like
when that would have been.
He,
he looks pretty different than here and we ended up not using it like a super
hot.
Was He really?
Yeah,
it was just red.
Oh Man.
Um,
so for people,
I mean obviously I've,
I talked about,
we used to do episodes when I was in Atlanta and between life weeks,
you know,
while we were going back and forth.
And then I've been talking about it coming up and then you and I went on Rogan
together last week.
But for the people that don't know,
instant family,
uh,
that you wrote and directed a,
I should say cowrote right?
Yeah.
With John,
John Worth,
Jon also produces and jobs there.
I'll every step of the way.
John's the best.
I haven't seen him since,
since this whole thing,
but,
uh,
I,
I mean I didn't run into him in anything,
but John is fantastic,
but this story is in,
is inspired by your life and uh,
it's about foster care and then you and your wife actually fostered,
adopted three siblings.
Yeah.
And,
and this,
so I think it's,
I was always thought it was important to note that,
that it's not just a guy going like,
we should write a movie about adopting.
Yeah.
And like try to hook people on that.
It's like,
it's influenced by something you really did.
Yeah.
It's amazing.
No,
it was,
you know,
after going through that process and being about three years into it,
it was actually John who said,
you know,
we should do a movie about this because you know,
none of us knew and I didn't know anything about it when I got involved in it.
And I was surprised there aren't that many things nowadays.
You know,
where you get into in the,
into a process and you're like,
oh,
I didn't
realize that you have to take these classes.
And I didn't realize that you've,
you know,
there's so many things about it that I didn't know.
Yeah.
And John didn't know.
So we thought,
well,
you know,
it would be good to shed some light on that stuff.
And also we thought we had sort of a unique perspective on it,
given that it is happening in my life and that so many movies that are made on
the topic really just focus on the sort of tragic elements of it.
But there's all these other elements of it too that are really wonderful and
full of love and laughter and all of that.
So we want it to be able to kind of cover all of it.
Oh my God,
it's awesome.
And I tell you,
I'm pretty much,
I'm a comic.
I'm cynical.
I made of Teflon for the most part.
I've cried on the show wants last,
last week.
When are we talking about the fire fire?
And I was crying,
but uh,
I'm telling you,
I am crying in a movie theater like that and so long and then the laughs and the
tiers,
it's really so unique in a movie.
You never,
you don't get to go on that much of a ride and it's such a well done film and
everyone goes,
see if for Thanksgiving this is a perfect week to,
it's a perfect way to go see it.
And it's,
wait,
how old are the kids now?
Well,
my kids are different ages than the kids in the movie.
Um,
so my kids are now 13.
Uh,
I hate it when there's that little pause and you're like,
oh,
I looked like the worst parent in the world.
Pause.
I'm like,
is it 13,
nine and eight?
I know my kid's age.
All right.
Um,
but no,
and it's one of the stories I like to tell about the movie that,
um,
when my wife and I got into it,
when you go see the movie,
you'll see that the characters go to this bizarre thing called an adoption fair,
which is a really controversial,
strange thing.
And we went to one because,
you know,
they,
the social workers invited us and we went there and it was one of the weirdest
things we've ever been to.
And we did meet a teenage girl there and her younger siblings,
like the characters in the movie.
And we did not,
we did not feel ready to sign up to have a teenager in our house.
But of course,
girl seem great.
She seemed really cool and we just thought,
all right,
so we wrote her,
we wrote them down on our sheet with just a lot of trepidation.
And then,
uh,
and then before anything happened,
they,
the social worker called and said,
these kids have been in care for four years and this teenage girl is really
holding out hope that her mom's coming back.
So she's refusing the placement.
So anyway,
that's why we have a teenager in the movie.
Cause I never forgot that girl.
And then when the time came to make the movie,
I really wanted to put a teenager in because those are the kids that really,
you know,
are misunderstood and yeah.
And uh,
but yeah,
my kids,
so what happened in my case was shortly after that,
our social worker called and said,
oh,
but there's these other three kids.
And that's how random it was.
It was just like,
okay,
there's these other three kids and they were six,
three and 18 months at the time.
Oh my God.
Yeah.
How did you do it?
I don't know.
It was,
it was horrible.
Well,
and especially going at first,
at first it was horrible because the normal,
I'm a normal,
whatever traditional route is,
you have a newborn and you're thrown that chaos
and that it's like your bootcamp for being a parent.
But you got like all three children at once.
Different stages.
We Really Thought,
oh my God,
no,
we can,
you know,
I mean,
we knew,
you kind of know intellectually there's a storm coming,
but like you don't,
you just don't realize.
Did you,
at the time
when you first got your children,
was it schools time where you like able to have it?
Yeah.
At least.
No,
that's a great question.
Nobody ever asks that question.
And that's the thing is that,
and they're strict about that stuff.
So it's like,
welcome to our home day one.
Okay.
And then our two younger were,
you know,
they didn't have to go to school,
but our oldest,
our son had to be like right into a new school like that day.
So you don't even get a minute.
You know,
I was like,
we had to go and sign them up.
And then it turned out the school that was closest to our house didn't,
was overfull so,
but the other one was like,
you know,
0.2 of a mile further or whatever.
And uh,
but no,
it's,
it was,
so,
it was just everything.
Immediately it was just school and teachers and kids.
And it was saying that tense.
Yeah,
it was intense.
Do you have the kids or the oldest or all of them seen the film?
Oh yeah.
And Oh they love it.
They've,
I mean they,
they don't see it because it's not,
it's not a bio pic about her family.
They recognize specific moments that they remember,
but they've been around for the whole thing,
including when I was talking about it when it was a script,
cause we'd be having dinner and I beat my wife and I or my kids would be trying
to remember certain things and then they would come to set and they were in the
Edit Bay and they've been around.
What a cool experience for them.
It's been a really cool for your wife.
Yeah,
I mean,
my wife,
one of the things I love about my wife is that she has absolutely zero craving
for the spotlight at all or anything.
Like,
you know,
my wife,
like if I did a podcast,
my wife would never be a part of it.
She would not have nothing.
No,
I'm sorry.
And if I did a podcast,
my husband,
so I mean,
I don't know,
it's your podcast.
So anyway,
uh,
no,
she just,
so this has been interesting because she has been,
you know,
in these interviews and in certain things and she's been great about it,
but she's kind of like reading,
reading,
reading.
Come you guys,
you must have some fun.
The one thing I was thinking about earlier today when you're on your way over
here,
it's like your children are Latin.
Um,
my mother is,
yeah.
And My mother looks distinctly Latin.
Right.
And like you,
yeah.
Like,
like me,
like my young,
my youngest,
it's weird the way genetics work because my younger sister looks like a carbon
copy of my mom.
Right.
And then I definitely,
my dad,
who's like a white boy,
white boy,
I just inherited,
you know,
the fair skin and everything.
And throughout my life,
I can tell you countless times where I'd be with my mom and talking to someone
and then they'd be like,
who's that lady?
That's my mom.
And they're like,
did she adopt you?
And I'd be like,
no,
that's actually my mother.
Uh,
do you run into,
um,
you know,
I guess you'll probably get it at some point.
It gets like countless looks or whatever,
but do people go,
like are those,
no,
I mean,
I mean so often,
you know,
either I'm just with the kids and I think people just assume that upon my wife
is,
is Latin or whatever.
You know,
and you know,
it's funny when we were going through the classes,
the,
the foster classes,
cause you have to take these like eight weeks of classes before you,
before you're certified.
And they talked about that a lot.
And people that get really jumpy about that,
about like,
well what are,
what are people going to say and how are people that,
you know,
and we,
we had that moment of how are people going to perceive this as far as us being
the white family and all of that kind of stuff.
But we didn't have any worry at all about like,
oh no,
people are going to know our kids are adopted.
I don't care if they know our kids are at that.
I mean,
and that's,
I think part of it is that people are,
I think nowadays people have a much better understanding that your,
you love your kids just as much,
if that's true,
this is a different era.
Or if there was a time I think for a long time that people would almost approach
it with pity.
Like,
oh you couldn't,
you have your own kids or whatever.
Whatever crazy things people would come up with.
But we don't know.
I don't,
I don't really know.
My older,
my older sister has,
um,
black hair and dark eyes and she married like basically a Nordic guy.
Yeah.
And so both of her children are blonde,
blonde,
blonde with blue eyes and everywhere.
She's like,
everywhere I go they ask me like if the mother knows that because they all
assume she's the nanny and it makes me so happy because they're like,
where does she live?
She lives in Florida.
And she was just like,
she was like,
she'll bring them in.
And they were like,
and then as I was their mother aware that and she's like,
I am their mother.
And they were like,
okay,
that's true.
Oh man,
she deserves it.
So this is the [inaudible].
Okay.
Are you ready to work before we do that?
The other thing that I just wanted to give you credit for it because you're the
only person that said this.
Um,
when you guys came to see the movie afterwards,
when we were talking afterwards,
you said that you loved that Pete Nelly who are played by Mark Wahlberg and
Roseburg seemed like a couple that actually loves each other.
And I was so happy that you said that because,
because as we were making the movie,
there were,
there were different people along the route that we're like,
they should be fighting more,
they should be attacking each other more.
And I was like,
you know,
that's not really how it was for us,
for my wife and I,
we,
you,
you kind of,
you have to kind of stick together a little bit in that situation.
Exactly.
But you're the only person who actually said that.
And I was made me so happy.
I called death and I was like,
you know what?
She said,
I'll,
I'll say this too.
I mean like we watch a lot of shows together.
One of the things that just over time that we've realized is that totally
removed from this film or story.
It's such a bummer to watch,
uh,
couples that don't like each other.
You know,
like in movies and entertainment.
Like you see all these shows,
like the show will be like,
here's the reality of marriage.
And then it's like,
um,
you know,
just bickering or the resentment and you're like,
okay.
I mean maybe that's some somewhat of reality,
but like,
I don't want to watch this.
I don't want to watch.
I got a piece of advice from a really good friend a long time ago and she said
that her mom gave her this advice that her mom told her,
you people are going to tell you your whole life that relationships are hard.
And she said it's not true.
Bad relationships are hard.
Relationships are relatively easy.
And I think,
I mean as,
as as dark and just crazy funny and bizarre of places that you guys go into on
this podcast.
As much as you guys might not want to admit it.
A huge secret to the charm of your podcast is how much you guys obviously enjoy
the show.
And it went well.
But yeah,
I liked watching the couple in your movie because they also had normal reactions
to extraordinary circumstances.
I don't know if you guys kept it in the movie,
the final cut,
but where's that one where Mark Wahlberg is kinda being like,
should we give them back?
Should we give them back
all the time?
Like do we make a big mistake?
It's really funny cause yeah,
the scene that you're referring to there,
they're just sort of at their wits and they're at a very low point.
They're lost,
they're scared.
And they're talking about,
there's gotta be some way back to the easy quiet life had before.
And my wife and I very much had that conversation.
I'm not proud of it.
But what I've found and I've been screening the movie for groups all across the
country,
it's really funny when you show it to regular general audiences,
they sort of gasp at that scene and then,
but then when you show it to adoptive families,
they roar at that scene because they're all like,
oh yeah,
we totally had a conversation like seven times.
Cause it's just,
it's a hard adjustment to make.
And then once you do make the adjustment,
it's the best thing that ever happened to you.
But you still have to get through that hard time first.
Of course
we just had our second baby.
So then you start to go like,
oh my God,
what did we do?
Like one was manageable.
One,
we could still leave the country too is like fucking chaos man.
Well I'm going to crush you right now.
Three is a great,
it's a great number.
I'm not alone.
It's shut down and shut it down.
I've said to her a bunch and she's yelled at me.
I was like,
come on.
Cause when they get a little bigger three,
well it,
that's why when they get a little bigger,
three is such a great number because they can kind of pair it if one of them
wants to be alone.
The other ones,
so somebody to play with and they kind of like,
it really is a,
it's a,
it's a more manageable number than you think.
I don't know.
No,
I didn't tell you this.
I mentioned this I think last week when we did that podcast.
But um,
the funny
thing is that ever since being in this movie and talking about it,
men emails left and right and messages left and right about people who either
have adopted are going to adopt or know someone that is adopting.
Yeah.
So you ended up learning what I mean.
And even one of my friends,
uh,
Greg told me that his sister and her husband are adopting four siblings this
week.
Oh Wow.
Yeah.
What are their names?
Um,
I don't know.
Oh,
who is it now?
Call me.
He's a comic in Minnesota and he was,
when you hear that,
what's,
here's what's so incredibly cool about that.
For siblings run such a high risk of being split up.
Here we go.
Greg Coleman,
my sister husband are adopting four kids next week.
One tire fam is going to see instant family next week as a warmup.
Good for them.
That's really cool.
Yeah.
I want to talk to
just add four.
Well now you know that when my wife and I,
when we went to that adoption fair,
we also met five girls that were between two and like 12.
And I just was watching these kids going like,
oh my God,
nobody.
Five kids.
And my wife was like,
there's no way.
Five.
Yeah.
And,
but we ended up,
this is how crazy we are that,
that when the thing with the teenager,
it didn't work out.
We did sort of,
cause we just kept thinking about these girls weren't like,
they're definitely gonna get split up.
They're going to get split up.
So we called the social worker and we were like,
what about these?
And she was like,
oh no.
They placed them all together,
a room and we were like,
oh good.
Oh good.
Yeah.
So,
um,
that's really made it,
it was like swinging five bats on the on deck circle,
you know,
in the end.
Cause it was like,
you know,
then after talking about five,
we're talking about a teenager.
All of a sudden three younger kids seemed a little more manageable.
It wasn't,
but it seemed,
it wasn't though really interesting.
And I like about your film too,
I think because I had just had our second child.
It's like you don't realize how complicating parenting,
how complicated parenting is until you really do it and you're like,
oh man,
there's so many emotions.
Like I go from like joy to anger to exhilaration to exhaustion all day.
You don't realize how crazy you are until the kids come in and sort of draw that
out and then you're like,
oh,
I'm a psychopath.
I had no idea that I was just insane.
I had this a full,
the two hours while you were gone with our big boy was I was like kind of a walk
with him that I'm on a notes call.
Yeah.
Doing a note on a walk with him and he's like trashcan.
And I'm like,
I go,
yeah,
that other scene we could probably
just like,
it just reminds me of bikes.
Like
you just have to surrender,
you know?
Right.
Like isn't there a point where you're just like fuck it,
it's just chaos.
And then he wrote on there on the couch,
got back and I was telling Shana,
I started to talk to him like he was going to give me a explanation.
I go,
why would you do that?
I told you not to do that.
He goes to five.
Yeah.
Dammit.
I know.
Anyways,
well we had this thing where where we always have these meetings,
like what?
We'll have dinner,
we'll be like,
okay,
it's going to be like family meeting night.
We're going to talk about whatever we need to talk about.
And my kid said to me at one point you shout too much.
And I was like,
I know I shout,
I hate shouting,
but you guys won't listen to any two,
one syllable that I say until I start shouting at you.
And then all of a sudden you're like all ears.
But up until then,
so then I said,
how about this?
How about I say I'm about to shout and when you hear I'm about to shout,
just take that as I'm already shouting and then,
and then listen to me and look at me.
And they were like,
okay,
all right,
we can do that.
And then it'd be like,
okay you guys,
you guys,
I'm about to shout.
I am about to shout.
And they'd be like,
whatever.
I'm gonna be like,
yeah,
keep shining.
Dammit.
I'm a chef.
I want to shout.
Oh,
you're going to shout a lot of two boys.
Yeah.
God dammit Shit.
Do you know who I wonder shouts.
Okay,
here we go.
Inside Studio g where music is first here.
And uh,
I like it that way.
Really cool.
I got uh,
uh,
is that supposed to happen right there?
Right there.
Brain.
You're a director.
Yeah.
That's a great emotional turnoff right there.
Yep.
Right.
I got it.
Cause this is like,
I'm thinking about this,
this supposed to happen.
I am thinking about reaching under someone's chest plate and then removing the
heart with my bare fucking hand.
See they see
me happy
birthday to G.
Okay Buddy.
Um,
bow,
I don't fucking,
do you ever get,
you knew about,
you knew about uh,
Chris Gaines,
right?
Yeah.
And He,
yeah,
that was his character alter ego,
right.
Oddly Song
in instant family that was written I believe for Chris Gaines,
really not performed by Chris Gaines,
but there isn't for him.
There's this beautiful song that we use near the end of the movie called it
don't matter to the sun.
And I think the first appearance of that song was on the Chris Gaines record and
then it was later.
It was later covered by Don Henley and um,
I think Stevie nicks or I can't remember exactly who could,
maybe it was just Don Henley and we definitely,
yeah,
some Chris Gaines stuff hundreds of episodes before,
but we've been talking about Garth so much that people have asked,
uh,
you know more about them.
I love this so much,
this era that we're going into,
I'm so,
I'm enthralled with him.
I'm fascinated by the psychology of this.
He's a fascinating person.
Here is a social media,
so people don't know.
Garth,
years ago got sick of his successful career as Garth Brooks.
Yes.
Decided he was going to play a alter ego.
Chris Gaines,
whose parents had died and he was doing different types of music.
I didn't know there was a backstory
question that I get about Chris Gaines is what's it like to play to different
people?
And the answer is,
first let's get one thing straight.
I'm not playing two different places.
If people I'm playing one,
uh,
the Garth Brooks thing,
it's just who I am.
Oh,
Chris Gaines thing though,
the closer you look and the more you find out,
you realize Chris Gaines is Garth,
so all it is is a stretching of the arms and all it is is taking Garth Brooks
and Chris Gaines and putting them together the same way.
We took a song from sixties and the 90s and put them together to create a new
song for the millennium.
It's probably the crossroads where Garth and Chris meet dead on and probably the
most,
they're like,
oh no,
this is the most sincere I've ever seen him.
When he's talking.
Well,
you know,
why do you know why?
Because Chris Gaines is his shadow self.
It's the darkness inside of him that he's finally addressing.
So when he's talking about the darkness,
he's alive.
One of my favorite love it.
That's actually a really good 10 years in psychotherapy.
Go ahead.
Also the Garth Brooks character,
even though he says that's just him,
my assumption is that it's him,
but it's also anytime you have a public persona like that,
that's a lot of work to kind of cap to keep that up and to be the,
well that's why it looks,
it seems what I'm telling you,
it feels contrived and more than anything it feels exhausting because there's
nothing natural about it.
Like he doesn't go like,
Hey,
I'm coming to your city.
He's like,
hi,
coming to your city.
I'm real.
I love y'all so much.
I just want world peace.
And you're like,
all right man.
Like no one talks like that.
Sounds like you're in a beauty pageant contest.
It feels forced.
I'm not saying he's not a nice guy.
I'm sure you think about them,
but,
but I just know that was especially,
I mean the guy was like the Michael Jordan of country music for like 10 years.
Oh yeah.
And uh,
so,
you know,
to just keep that up has got to be exhausting.
So to,
to just pretend like you're somebody else for a while had to be like the most
funny,
bad,
you know,
he took so much time off.
He took a famous,
he is,
he took a lot of time off,
um,
to,
I think it was to raise the kids as well.
I'm sure it was just a very bodies,
but it was,
he was taking,
raising kids and then now he's back on tour.
He's doing stadium football stadiums and they are selling out like in an hour,
like stadiums.
But this was him also explaining how he,
uh,
photographs differently for Chris Gaines.
The hard thing about the plane,
Chris Gaines as actual person that you're filming is for a guy that's 220 pounds
to try and look small and Chris's this supposedly kind of a smaller built
artists.
So in all the pictures,
it's easy.
Go see photos of you suck your cheeks and your face becomes real thin.
You can do that.
The problem is I may start seeing these bigger cheeks come out again.
We know Chris will be the first one to tell you when his biography that he's had
a lot of great relationships that he has personally thrown away himself.
So,
uh,
when it comes to women and when it comes to commitment,
Yup.
He's not really the first guy in Russia.
Shadow self.
There is a darkness.
This,
uh,
like a Vegas,
like not a,
you know,
not an Andy Kaufman thing,
but like,
uh,
you know,
you should do a skinny guy,
cool guy.
Like not that you're not skinny and cool,
but right here you should do like a,
you know,
you should do an alter ego comic with long hair.
Yeah.
It just does like really,
you know,
stuff that only 15 year olds get right.
You know?
Yeah.
You have rodeo.
I did do Rodeo for a while.
I don't know this one.
Rodeo,
uh,
would do urban rooms and even wear oversized white tee shirts.
He had like a pencil,
thin beer and then he had a call,
he'll go,
hey,
ho Rodeo.
So like for the punch,
but I would do only like hack premises.
Like you got to hit your kids,
man.
Yeah.
You probably make a fortune though right now.
Yes.
Just blow,
blow myself out of the water.
Yeah.
Like my age was like,
you've got to stop touring as yourself.
Yeah.
They don't want that anymore.
And he stuck with Brianna.
Oh,
can I say before I forget,
I was so excited.
This is so corny,
but so excited to hear about house and your mood.
Oh,
third uncle dude.
He's the greatest ever again.
Only other person.
Only person to ever mentioned that.
Yeah.
What a great song.
Very observant.
Yeah.
Are you,
do you like golf music?
Is that where you got that?
I don't know.
Not Goth music that you'd like.
I'm not like,
you know,
uh,
an aging goth or anything,
but I did really,
I always really loved about how send Peter Murphy and love and rockets and,
yeah.
What the fuck now,
how did you that's I didn't know.
Oh good.
I love that stuff.
Both used to go to the lesbian clubs.
A lot of do you mean the clubs?
The golf club.
Wow.
I was so impressed because I never hear,
I'm never heard that song in a movie.
And I was like Tommy,
that's Bauhaus.
That's about,
that's such a great,
oh,
exciting.
Yeah.
No I didn't say that.
Chris said that.
Oh it's better.
So anyway,
this guy comes out with this long hair and he hides up for three or four years
cause he's really not happy with his face,
which upset me.
But you know,
and you kind of look like Prince.
Yeah.
Except this guy gained a lot of weight after the,
Oh,
so this is explaining to Chris.
Look,
he's what he looks like showing them the checks 11.
Yeah,
of course.
Okay.
Is that the unveil?
Oh yeah.
If that was unveiling Chris Gaines audience.
Yeah.
That's bizarre.
It's just,
no,
Shawn was saying he has,
he has,
he can't put any to,
um,
people were,
he's heard on our show.
Oh,
see,
I don't,
I don't want this
know the first time anyone's ever said that on her show.
I listened.
I was saying the time that I only
here your show cause I'm always driving when I'm listening to it.
So I haven't seen any of these linear tech center,
but the pictures in my mind are,
are at frankly worse than that,
so.
Okay.
All right.
I got it.
How's on asphalt bell and their SAS.
Dot.
Barkow Woo.
I want to see if I can't,
I gotta be careful here.
Sorry Jesus.
I can't believe him.
Biggest takeaway.
I want to see that guy.
You don't want to see the forest road guy.
Do you have
of research person that digs for this stuff or is it all you?
No,
no,
no.
We have a,
we would now have to staff.
Um,
so people will send in emails,
your mom's podcast@gmail.com.
It sometimes gets like 5,000 plus emails a week.
I know.
And that they have to,
we'll have to work at in tandem to just dig through.
Have you told the story on your show about when the video,
when the trailer for the movie first hit?
Um,
well,
there's a couple things that are pretty funny happened recently.
There's the trailer,
which is now,
by the way,
that trailer,
if we do a youtube,
let's see,
um,
instant family.
It is 100%.
Uh,
it has 10 million views.
The trailers,
I mean for a trailer,
right?
It's,
it's pretty nutty.
Um,
he's a really special,
what kind of people who volunteer with just not even a holiday.
We don't even volunteer.
Holiday
over a half moon.
Children are currently in foster care.
The county puts his arm because they can match a lot of kids and parents quickly
look at the big kiss.
Everybody's avoiding.
I was going to go and say hi if they're teenagers.
Okay.
There just drugs and they watch people playing video games and Youtube.
We're not equipped for any of that.
Just Fyi.
Can all hear you?
Hmm.
Okay.
Let me go with the kitties and don't give it another thought.
Bye.
She was cool.
Lizzy comes with two younger siblings.
Three kids,
two mice.
Oh my God,
why would you show us that's wrong.
Make yourself at home because you're at home.
Do you like more of a Lakers fan?
Oh No,
you hit me because I like the clippers and the clippers are awesome.
They were smart for trading.
Blake Griffin.
Just stay there until the fire department comes.
Okay.
All right.
There's um,
this trailer has almost 11 million views now.
And if you go in here,
look,
the third comment,
Tommi bonds,
I want,
no,
I want this out right now.
Right now,
this is from art show,
but I know a deep adopt me feed me,
try it out.
Highest and Titus trailer I've ever seen.
So here's what happened.
The marketing people at paramount,
wonderful people,
good people,
they're very nice.
But they,
they,
they put up the trailer and you know,
it's always kind of like,
okay,
they worked really hard on this thing to try to,
you know,
get the message across of what the movie is and then they want to see how people
react to it.
And the reactions were really,
really positive,
but mixed in were all of these cryptic was on from,
from your fans.
And they were like,
and it took everybody like a few beats to be like,
what's going on with this trait?
What the hell is high and tight?
And,
uh,
and then they called me to tell me,
um,
that I I knew at that point but they called me to tell me those are just Tom
Segura is fans.
They love him.
And,
and uh,
I,
it was,
it's been really fun.
And now with people,
what I love is that there are these great people have been posting these great,
you know,
your fans have been posting these great,
things on Instagram or whatever that are sort of admitting that as cynical as
kind of humor that they liked.
They are so many of them are really digging the movie and obviously loving
Thomas.
And I think,
cause there's real,
that moment I was discussing earlier with a,
they're like,
oh my God,
what have we done?
There's real moments of,
it's funny,
but it's also real plate.
There's nothing corny about this movie.
Do you know what I'm saying?
Oh God,
it's really good.
Genuine.
It had to,
they finally got to editing some of the IMD be a trivia,
which for a month just name it was.
Yeah,
it was just,
yeah,
I'm on that right now there though.
The top piece of Trivia still says Tom who stars as Russ was famously known as
the water champion as well as beating the world's fattest man Bark Grizzler
weight loss.
That's obviously not true
or that's not trivia for movie fans.
Kind of is.
This right here.
This is just an actual review of the film based on a true story by a director
Shawn Andrews at home family life.
It's a full review of it.
The film is bolstered by a strong supporting cast.
Tom Cigarette keeps things high and tight as the impishly maniacal husband of
Ellie's baby,
crazy sister.
It is a small role,
but I notable one as Sigora efforts effortlessly adapts his warmly sociopathic,
comedic stylings,
unbelievable.
And then they code go onto like write a really great review but unbelievable how
you guys,
I love warmly sociopathic.
Everyone's hitting me up with that right now.
So yeah,
I don't know that anybody's ever been described that way.
Yeah.
And I don't know.
I wouldn't ever will be not an easy thing to be warmly associates.
This show started kind of uniquely like that.
What did she say?
Tommy was started as like
a dance between it.
Originally it was Tommy and I playing GG Allen.
Do you know Gigi?
Yeah.
We love that documentary.
Hated so good.
And then we played another documentary.
Stevie all sort started the dark weird.
We like Stevia.
And then what happened is that there is people that were like,
yes,
we like weird too.
And then they kept emailing it and then we kept playing it and now it's,
it's listener generating,
enjoying show that he does Milana.
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
I know that.
Or you'll take a lot out of you.
Oh yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Don't watch that at the beginning of your weekend.
Yeah.
Wow.
When you woke up to a rattlesnake.
Crazy.
Yeah.
Um,
okay.
So here's the other way.
If you guys ever seen my brother's keeper,
wait,
is that about a slow adult?
Sorry,
what's about these three old men in upstate New York?
I lived on a farm and one of them murdered the other one.
Put it on your list.
It's very darkly disturbing.
Interesting.
Just that weird.
I guarantee a lot of your listeners a little bit about,
I'm talking,
by the way,
did ted,
you seen tip toes?
I know,
you know it's funny,
I was just,
as I was driving over here,
I hadn't caught the last episode yet,
so I was just catching up on the last episode.
That is,
are you making that up?
Is that,
that sounded like as I thought they must have just cut something together.
Seemed like,
now I will say this.
Um,
has that happened?
How does that movie get me?
Well,
and the funny thing is when you said the date,
you said like,
oh three or something,
which doesn't seem long ago enough for that to have happened.
No,
because if you hadn't told me that,
oh yeah,
in 1983 they did this and be like,
all right,
right.
But really permissible in 83.
Well,
and they said,
I mean,
at least this was later.
They want.
Somebody said that the,
there was a cut of the movie that was actually great.
And you know,
that happens with right,
gets fired.
And then the studios like edit it like this.
And I mean not to tip toes.
I mean they know.
This is really,
I see.
I only heard it,
I didn't see it together.
It was perfect.
Oh,
weird.
To me,
the blow job,
I've got to get going like this right in the trailer.
Yeah,
it's a bit forward.
You know,
there's one small problem and the voiceover,
Sarah Monroe,
I'm his brother.
We're twins and it's Gary Oldman's carry homes.
Parents.
Wait,
that's Gary Oldman.
I'll do a little gut.
Yeah,
it can tear them apart.
I you kind of let me know that everyone in your pants is images or not images.
Carolyn doors bring them together.
And the voiceover,
I was so obsessed with like the,
like the like comedy sounding like,
it's like,
like if you were making a parody,
you would have this guy right over
welcome.
I'm Steven are just the Steven's father,
ms mom,
Kathleen,
and over behind the bar students.
By the time he could've prepared us for this study.
Think Bass me,
I'll never speak to cancer.
She's get it together
and they treat them like they're like,
you have aliens.
I know
people.
Yeah.
It's like,
like,
I mean these people with disabilities.
Fuck no heads up on that.
You could have told me he's in a wheelchair.
Right.
That's the weird stuff.
It's only the size of your heart that counts.
Make it that big of a deal.
If a kid does it work,
you're not telling this great girl and you didn't tell her that her baby's
probably going to be lit.
I'm not like you.
We also cute and cuddly.
Don't discriminate against us.
Well,
they're also southern and little,
which is interesting.
Gary Oldman is English,
right?
Yes.
Wow.
Well Peter Dinklage right there had like a French accent where he was a friend
and you know,
choices.
They let them make choices.
You know,
what was the occasion or something?
I guess he just got nowhere to what Matthew mcconaughey.
Um,
I believe he play twin brothers with we.
Yes.
I was his smaller twain.
This is tip toes,
tip toe,
which he played the tour.
I did play it off.
How was that experience?
It was um,
you know what it was,
it was,
uh,
I must say it was a little,
it was a little strange.
It didn't turn out as well as we thought it might.
It's one of those where you,
I mean it's all a roll of the dice I guess,
but you know,
it's not my finest hour on Salvia Lloyd.
I really wonder because it is an incredible shame if,
because you know,
you've seen where they take the shining and they recut the trailer and make it
look like a romantic comedy.
Yeah.
And it is amazing what can be done with music and cuts and whatever.
And it would be really heartbreaking to have to find out that this was some
beautiful movie.
Peter Dinklage said that it was a,
yeah,
you said that he said that it was a trailer was cut in properly.
Well,
he said the film ended up getting,
like the studio changed the entire film,
but there was a cut of that was,
he said it was great and that it just completely got to get ahold of this
though.
Yeah,
but the title
low to range,
because I spent all the shooting time on my knees with and I worked with,
with real little paypal,
you know,
so I would say,
okay,
that's,
you know,
one hour lunch and I would stand up.
I thought the thing that made me think it was a parody when it was just
listening to it was the title and the way the guy said this idol tip toe.
Yeah.
It's like an SNL.
It does it.
Does it seem Marie?
Oh Man.
Okay.
Are you ready to do it?
What would I ask you?
Yeah.
All right.
This is what I was telling you.
I don't know why I agreed to do this.
This is my idea.
She was greeted with yourself.
I agree with to do this,
but the reason I think,
I think I did it because I actually,
when you like someone you don't mind feeling vulnerable around crying and all I
do is make fun of people.
You know,
we make fun of people.
So I feel like this could be so embarrassing,
but you know,
I'm just going to go for it.
I asked Sean to pull my audition.
Oh my God.
I'm embarrassed.
I'm embarrassed right now.
I'm shaking.
So she blushing.
I am,
uh,
it's,
it's mortifying.
Can't watch that.
See no sign.
So painful to watch these things.
I know,
but I'm probably,
you probably did great.
Thank,
I don't know.
I did.
Um,
additions are so harsh.
We had a telestrator for this.
Uh,
okay.
Hold on,
hold on.
Uh,
do you do a lot of auditions?
I not a lot,
but sometimes if I like it,
yeah.
Do you know if I do?
My sister's an actor.
And so what we do when we,
when we run auditions is we always have a note out in the lobby that just lets
people know you're coming into a friendly room.
We're like,
we just let him know that,
hey,
if you want to try some things,
like whatever you want to do is cool with us.
Because I just,
when I,
when I have to audition people,
I feel like the biggest jerk in the world because it's just one person after
another coming in and we're just destroy their dreams.
One,
one after it all.
I had to prepare characters and sketches and things.
The Perth,
the casting person will be typing the entire time and I'm like,
I smell that's like a week preparing these,
you know,
I've had somebody,
um,
I've had somebody read emails as I was auditioning for them.
Yeah,
that's,
that's the worst.
Yeah.
This is my Julia,
this is my version though.
Julius is Mike.
Good Morning Julia.
Okay,
so the reason I asked him to do this,
because Sean,
actually one thing that never happens when you auditioned for anything is that
you talked to the director afterwards and he tells you about the audition.
You know what I mean?
How it went.
Very rare you don't get to hear any,
you never hear.
And I'm Elaine by the way.
To be clear,
that's what's so brutal about auditioning is that you have to go in for,
and you can't blow it off.
You have to go in and prepared if you,
if you want to have a shot at it.
And so often on our side of it,
we're looking for something really specific.
So more often than not,
as soon as somebody walks in the door,
you're like,
ah,
you just know they're not quite right.
And every now and then somebody will surprise you and you'll go,
oh,
okay,
this isn't what we had in mind,
but this is different.
This is cool.
Um,
but it's,
it really is.
I told my sister,
I said,
you need to,
to be a reader at auditions.
It'll take the pressure off because you just see one person after another coming
in.
And the best thing you can know going in,
especially for the colder,
the audition is,
is just,
no,
you're not getting it.
Just go in just knowing this and just gives a show,
be nervous.
Just have a good time with it.
And because if you do,
you do.
And you know,
but it's,
it's rough.
It is rough.
It's interesting what Joe Rogan,
I,
when I just did his podcast a couple weeks back was saying,
uh,
you just can't really give a shit when you go in for auditioning,
auditioning auditions,
like for fear factor.
He kind of went in,
he was saying as a joke,
he's like,
is this real?
Yeah.
And he was kind of shitting on it and they're like,
you're the guy.
Yeah.
I think the thing is too,
it's like you,
um,
like even talking to Sean about the,
this mood,
like right before I would,
you know,
read the script and he would give me some insight about like another character,
like,
oh yeah,
but the person who plays that should be like this.
And I was like,
ah,
I see.
I didn't even pick up on that.
Rereading this reading.
I read your script and I,
and I thought that this part should be played by this type of actor.
And he was like,
well,
no,
because Bob a lot.
But hearing that insight about that.
Yeah,
totally made me go like,
oh,
see,
like I,
I didn't even know how that part should,
we played method on set.
I was very [inaudible] people couldn't hear him talk to him.
Okay.
You wear that jacket the whole time.
This is a,
this is fine.
I think this was my original.
Oh my God,
I can't,
can I leave and can you read it?
I know you're going to love this
because I feel you're,
yeah,
like I get it.
Oh fuck.
Halfway across town to see the shingle play.
Just having a little vision.
I mean,
once we exposed
the patio,
there's bunch of stripey shadow
structure.
Fantastic.
And if you have a baby,
I mean,
when you had a baby,
we are having a baby.
We are having
to manifest,
but what we want,
it wouldn't have been paying out.
You know,
I'm just playing.
It's gonna happen.
Hey,
I know this place is so great.
Why don't you guys flip?
It's not bad.
I'm not,
I'm not more than fine.
This
was what was wrong though,
right?
There's no,
no,
no.
We talked about,
we talked about this.
Yeah.
So here's the,
here's the other thing that's funny about a lot of people don't realize about
auditions too,
is that f as the writers,
you're hearing people do the dialogue and they're always doing sort of like the
longest version of the scene.
And when you read a lot of people that really helps you to cut down the scenes
and figure out what to keep and what to let go of.
But the poor actors,
they've had to go and do like the longest,
most tedious version of shorting possible.
Um,
so that's part of what we're seeing here too.
But no.
So to give you some,
some insight on this,
I was on Skype while he was doing this and it wasn't bad.
There was nothing bad about that.
But,
but there was a problem with it.
And the problem was he wasn't warmly sociopathic.
No,
you don't.
You know what it was,
it was,
his jeans were loose.
It was missing his low resting heart rate.
That is what it was missing because he had,
but if you watch what he's doing,
he's,
he's good.
He's,
he's funny,
but he's just like,
he's trying harder than he tries,
requires the w cause cause what I really responded to when I saw his stand up
was I liked this kind of leaned back that he would say kind of sometimes
outrageous things,
but just say I'm like,
alright,
you know,
I just said that.
So what,
you know.
Right.
And then when he came in for the audition,
he was more like here,
like just sort of laying into it.
And I was like,
oh shoot.
But I didn't know cause he had been in anything else.
I didn't really have any frame of reference.
Is this,
oh,
is this just the choice or can he not do that?
Your resting heart rate.
Yeah.
I love serial killer.
I mean I've never been in a movie.
Oh No.
Uh,
but Phil,
I guess film acting too,
I mean your head is huge.
So minimal acting,
right?
Like you have to kind of play it smaller than you would if you were on stage.
Yeah,
I mean,
yes,
no,
depending on what you're doing,
sometimes you gotta go the other way because sometimes you know,
I think with this guy,
yeah,
he had to be bold without seeming like he was making an effort to be born.
Right.
Um,
because also his character is a little bit,
um,
dominated by his wife in,
in place.
Right.
So he had to be,
you know,
that guy who is just kind of that sort of devil may care guy.
But when he does care is when he just doesn't want to piss off his wife.
Wow.
You know,
um,
girls
aspects and Russ,
Danny don't go busted my balls on Turkey day.
Okay.
It's hard to watch.
I can't do it anymore.
Please.
She's asking me to stop.
I know what that is.
I've done these.
It's fucking mortified.
The thing is,
you know,
a song like even asking you to send these,
which I'm so happy you did.
I started to get that thing of like what if every audition I've ever done could
be accessed?
No.
How embarrassing would it be to showcase all your auditions?
Like,
cause this is one where ultimately it worked out right?
Cause like I booked a job but um,
I think about all the ones I went on where you walk out and you're like,
oh my God,
that was so bad.
Like when you know what's bad and what is that?
What is that in our brains anyway that does that to ourselves where it's like
you're doing this thing,
you're putting yourself out there,
you're,
you're being bald,
you're taking chances.
You're,
that's the only way you're getting anywhere near anything that,
that you know,
big in this world.
But we're so mortified by all of that.
I think you know what it is.
It's like,
I mean for I can I say it for this,
it's like you're,
you feel like you're,
when I'm showing this,
that I'm showing something where I was trying.
Yeah.
And sometimes the truth is
we all have these standards where you want to be seen as great without
effortlessly.
Yes.
So you want to be like,
oh you want to see my audition and someone sees it and you want to feel like
everyone would be like,
that's amazing.
At anytime.
It's not that you kind of are a little bit,
depending on how far from that it is embarrassed by it,
you know you want it to be good.
I mean for Standup,
you know,
Oh God,
we at least get to showcase that one time where we prepare,
prepare and prepare and it's,
you know,
it's months of like preparing and you show that and you go like,
okay as well it's near as good as it can be.
And even then sometimes,
I mean if my standup came on right now I'd be like,
okay,
we can turn that off.
Like I don't want to see myself do it stand up.
I've always thought that this is what's really interesting about standup is that
a huge component of standup is being self deprecating of,
of acknowledging whatever your own folly is or whatever.
Right?
So you're supposed to be up there presenting like,
I dunno,
I'm just this regular goof ball of a person and this is just what I think about
things.
But at the same time you're supposed to be this entertainer and,
and you're supposed to be kind of cool on some level and it's a,
it's a tough balance to get all that to where,
and so much of it is just making all these people feel comfortable so that they
can laugh.
Right.
You know,
cause that's the thing,
like you've seen comics where they just,
they immediately,
they make you uncomfortable and you're like,
I don't,
it doesn't matter what this guy's going to say.
Yeah.
I just feel so bad for him right now.
No,
I mean I think thank God with standup at,
they'll probably with everything,
but with stand up,
you know,
the longer you're the one doing it,
you start to feel more comfortable with all the elements of it.
Right.
The performing and the writing and the,
you know what I mean?
But I had the dream to do it when I was younger and I didn't really,
the nerve,
I'm not going to lie to you,
I never had the nerve.
I was just like,
it's a healthy him.
That's what I loved.
That that was where you,
let me see what many different components to stand up that I think it's a
psychology game tail because you're reading the audience,
you're reading everything,
you're seeing them.
By the way,
one of the reasons I brought this up was that last week when Sean and I were on
Joe's thing,
he talked about how how it lit I lit,
I leaned into this one but then he actually called me and I remember I worked on
it.
I don't have any of those,
but I'm just want to see just two more sentences.
We got some news.
Okay.
Okay,
I see.
I see it now.
I do a little,
it was dialed up a little bit.
Was that up a little bit?
Yeah.
No,
so what happened was I,
I called him cause I was in Atlanta and I,
and the other thing was I also had really high hopes.
I was really excited that you were coming to read for Russ and I like you
already had the job
but you didn't.
But I did.
I saw it and I was like,
oh no,
I don't know if this is going to work completely because
I need that.
I need that,
that,
that thing.
I need that,
that sort of relaxed vibe around it with this guy.
And uh,
so then I called him and I said,
would you be willing to come and work on it?
And by the way,
that's also really cool for somebody to just say,
sure,
I'll take time out of my day and not knowing if I'm good at it.
And it's cool for someone to offer to work on it.
More importantly,
I think it's cool.
Yeah.
Well,
and what we did more than anything is really,
it's not like we were just practicing it all day.
We were mostly just talking about it.
Like you said,
just talking about the character,
talking about the movie.
And it was really fun.
And um,
you gave me this note
by the way,
during filming a few times to like,
uh,
just like throw it away to chill out,
lean back,
don't,
yeah.
You brought that up.
I remember that a few times.
Yeah.
Throw it away was was always good for us.
Yes.
Just let it get out there and don't,
you know,
but I like also,
just so you know,
told him this,
I confessed that when I left this audition,
this one that clearly was not what he was looking for,
that I call my agent and I was like a knock that shit out of him.
That was hilarious.
I was like,
oh,
would be amazed if he does it.
And then he called me,
he was like,
he,
he said,
I remember.
He goes,
he,
he didn't say it was,
it was perfect.
He said,
you know,
that you could,
uh,
maybe an improve it.
Like he was so delicate.
I was like [inaudible] saying,
he said,
could he call you?
And I was like,
yeah,
you can call me.
You know what's interesting now that you say that.
Okay,
how come it's the auditions?
You think you've nailed it and you're like,
I am.
But it's always,
you never get the call.
And no times that I've always gone in there and been like,
I don't give a fuck.
I actually went in one time,
I auditioned for a commercial and I did not give a fuck so bad that I was eating
their snacks,
like the casting people.
I was going to eat their pretzels and they're like,
do you want to do this?
And I was like,
Oh yeah,
sorry.
Bye.
Buh Buh.
And I booked it.
It was a national commercial.
I made a ton of money and I never,
I didn't even think I'd get it.
That's
the,
and that,
that's kind of a huge secret to life right there.
And they actually,
for John and I,
it's been the same way on the writing.
The writer,
his version of that is pitching.
Pitching is ridiculous.
It is a nightmare because it's like an audition that goes on for a half an hour.
It's,
it's brutal.
And Yeah,
cause you have to go in there and you have to tell them the entire movie,
but you can't tell him the entire movie because I mean,
if I sat down and told you the entire movie of Star Wars,
you'd be bored to tears in 10 minutes,
you know?
So Boba Fett guy.
Yeah,
exactly.
yeah.
So you have to find some way to make your story interesting,
not just as a movie,
but as of you telling it in the room and you have to bring energy to it.
Because if you just go in and go,
look guys,
it just goes like this and this and this and that.
I mean,
sure,
if you're a superstar or they'll go,
great,
well buy anything you have.
But when you're out there trying to make your bones,
it's,
you got to go in there and you got to put your back into it and you've got to
sell.
And I do not like selling.
I've never,
my brother is a salesman.
I could never do it.
So I just go in there and it's exhausting.
And,
but like you're saying,
there were times where John and I would go in on something and you know,
like a rewrite job or something and we'd be like,
Eh,
you know,
we,
we talk about it and we'd kind of go in and we didn't give a shit.
You know,
we'd go in and we'd be like,
well,
I dunno,
I wouldn't do it like that.
I mean,
I would do it more like this.
I Dunno,
you know?
And they'd be like,
great,
you're hired.
But anytime we were just like so desperate to get the job,
it would just be like,
get everything relaxed,
see your essence,
and I can see who you are.
It's the dating.
If you're like,
I love you,
but after you're like,
uh,
I mean,
whatever,
I'm not that interested.
Then the person's like,
oh,
I'd love to go out with you always like that.
It's not about not caring because that's also I think really unappealing to
people acting like you don't give a shit about anything.
It's about,
it's about being confident in whatever choices you're making at the time and,
and more than anything,
being confident that if you don't,
if this thing you're doing right now isn't successful,
that you're going to go on survivor.
There's zero.
It has to have an in all facets,
no desperation because people can read when you're desperate for work or love or
anything like that.
And I think the reason why that that happens like that naturally is because if
you are desperate,
you're not going to do a very good job of it.
Right.
So I think people can read that and I think it's valuable that if somebody is
just so desperate to whatever it is that they're doing it,
it's probably not going to work out very well.
Yeah,
I was gonna say they needed too much.
This experience also like just for other actors.
I would say it showcased to me the nearly,
I won't say totally,
but like the near almost nearly impossible task of getting cast in a feature
studio film without previous experience.
It really is a hurdle,
right?
Like you,
you really need allies.
Like I had you wanting me to be in this and it's like it's still,
you start,
you know,
you start seeing how movies are cat cause you know,
you realize that studios go like,
well who has done this before?
Who has a track record like this?
Sometimes it's that because in your case,
I don't think anybody at the studio quite had an idea of what you're following
was.
I didn't either to be honest.
I had seen your,
your specials on Netflix and I just thought they were brilliant.
Um,
I think what it is more than anything is that through your stand up,
you were cultivating,
you were digging down,
drilling into your personality and different aspects of your personality.
And in this business you have so many people that have been doing Shakespeare
from the time that they were young and they are good at being actors,
but they,
they sometimes can lose track of who they are as people.
And that's what you're looking for more than anything you're looking for.
Who's behind those eyes that can bring something to this part beyond just,
there's a lot of people that can deliver the dialogue and make it sound
reasonably,
you know,
believable.
But it is hard,
right,
to get cast.
I mean,
oh no,
it's,
it's very hard.
But what I'm saying is that it's not so much about knowing that somebody has
experienced or whatever,
it's,
it's the,
somebody coming in and bringing some humanity into whatever it is that they're
doing and that's what the experience allows people to do.
I think particularly with Standup,
I think the reason why,
you know,
like Chris rock is a really good actor.
I mean,
so many standups are really good actors.
Adam Sandler is an amazing actor,
you know,
and I think it's because you've got to go out there on stage and just sort of
like put yourself out there over and over again.
Sure.
In front of so many different people.
You're going to drill down into who you really are.
Yeah.
I can do to be good at it.
And I think about a lot of time because if you're fake on stage,
everybody,
yeah,
no,
I know.
And that's why you people bomb.
It's because the audience can smell the inauthenticity or if you're terrified
like that,
that comic you were talking about feeling uncomfortable,
it may have been his terror that
they're like,
it's like an animal thing right away.
They're like dogs,
but doesn't everybody have to start a start there?
Do y'all have the experience fuck up for years and bombing and like horrible,
horrible.
They're emotionally traumatizing experiences big about like comedians and their
humanity.
I always think about a Robin Williams.
Oh my God.
Because,
um,
you know,
it was like,
I was like,
man,
like he really that read so much whenever he was on screen.
Yeah.
Um,
just like the human being that was there,
you know,
that like,
oh yeah,
you really connected with it.
Like I would see him and you know,
he played countless roles,
but like in especially like in a drama or something or even when he was in a
comedy during like the dramatic scenes that balanced the movie out,
man,
you always felt like,
wow,
I really am.
See the person here.
Yeah.
You know?
When he wasn't being funny and,
and to,
and I don't think it's any coincidence that so many standups who you just think
of,
oh,
that that guy or that woman is really good on stage,
that it's no coincidence that they are effortlessly be able to,
or they're able to turn in these,
these roles.
I mean,
Sarah Silverman,
so many people that have done these incredible roles in movies that you know
that if,
if you're one of those people that started acting lessons when you were four
years old,
it must be,
it must drive you a little crazy to see somebody who's been telling jokes and
bars for 10 years,
come,
come in and just crush like that.
But I think the reason why is because they're also doing this something really
similar to what you're doing when you're,
when you're pursuing acting at that level,
you're just drilling down into who you are.
Yeah,
and I also think too,
I think what's great about being a comic is that there's a level,
like you can be successful,
but then you can also eat shit every week.
Like you're never too on your own koolaid
check.
You can check it all,
but like your ego,
there's not a lot of bullshit.
Well,
after a while too,
you learn to not listen to that,
which is a really funny thing.
Like,
in other words,
you'll be on such a good streak of like great shows,
but you won't buy into,
Oh,
I'm amazing.
Because you'll know that it's not true.
You'll know like keep your self grounded.
Right.
Because this shit can go sideways quickly so you don't,
you actually don't buy into getting lost in all my shows go well
you've seen people before you who have risen and risen and risen and then
started to fall off for whatever reason.
People had kind of gotten used to what they were doing and they,
you know,
so,
so you never know.
I mean,
the way I look at it for me is that when did you look at anybody's imdv page?
It stopped somewhere.
Yeah.
There aren't that many people,
particularly directors or writers where it just goes on and on and on and
usually it's sort of,
it just stopped somewhere.
So you,
hey,
you want to be grateful for whatever time you have and be,
you want to always keep that in the back of your mind that this isn't a gravy
train that just goes on.
What do you tell yourself?
Like you just go,
like,
we'll just keep working,
keep doing the work.
Yeah.
I mean,
John and I,
we've always seen ourselves as pretty blue collar and that way we know we're not
geniuses.
We know that we work for a living and we get together every day and we sit in a
room and we talk about nonsense and we just just keep poking and prodding at it
until it comes together in some way.
And we try not to ever turn in drafts that don't hold up,
you know?
And uh,
but,
but everything that we're doing is so subjective.
You can write a scene that you think is the greatest scene ever written and
there's going to be somebody that's going to go,
ah,
it's a piece of shit.
Yeah.
Kind of an asshole would read that.
So,
so there's no way you can ever,
you can say you can't write for them though,
but you,
but you can't.
It's like what you're saying,
you can't ever think that you've got it all figured out because you just never
will,
you know,
so you just keep doing the work.
Listen,
I,
uh,
I had such a good experience with you.
I want to thank you again for the opportunity.
Thank you.
Awesome.
I feel like I won a contest.
I think I did.
And um,
we,
uh,
we've had fun with you here.
I want to encourage everybody.
I know I got a ton of messages this week,
man,
from people that were like,
I'm going the movie just to see you like tea to me.
And they're like,
I ended up loving the movie.
I was not expecting this.
I wasn't expecting to cry.
Fuck you,
you piece of Shit and go to a movie where I cried.
Stuff like that.
Um,
but I think you made an amazing film and I'm happy to be a part of it and it's
Thanksgiving week and I want to encourage everybody to go see it and bring
people a,
it's an awesome movie.
Yeah,
thanks.
And by the way,
thank you for being in the movie.
I mean you,
you brought a ton
to it.
And even just having you on set with that attitude of being so excited to be
there at,
I mean,
that's really valuable to me.
It relates to being in movies.
I know keep people who this thing and they get used to it.
I mean,
I gotta admit I'm,
I'm a little bit too used to being on set and sometimes that's what's great
about having somebody who comes in who's not there all the time,
is that it's a good reminder of like,
Oh yeah,
we get to make them.
I was little is that I was like,
God,
I stand here and watch the monitors and then were like,
yeah,
I like,
I was like somebody visiting set and there's free food everywhere.
It was great.
And that's like the fucking crazy.
I mean you,
you met half of them have the,
of using actors,
Haggerty so much.
She's so great.
And our,
our grandma,
Grandma Sandy,
Marco,
Marco.
And I love her because she's,
my younger sister was like,
I'm so proud of you.
It was awesome.
I love it.
And I got thanks.
She goes,
I thought Grandmas,
Sandy was the best.
Okay.
No,
she's so great.
I feel like,
I feel like one thing I could do,
um,
that I could borrow from Trump is the,
uh,
is the way he,
he has this like self promoting thing that he does really well,
but I think an actor could do,
which is,
um,
he'll be like,
a lot of people are saying this and so I'm going to just start going.
A lot of people are saying it's the performance of a lifetime.
Yeah.
Or he'll be here in that.
He'll be like,
I keep,
I'm talking to,
and they're just saying that,
you know,
that they've never seen,
but everybody's saying everybody or a is incredible when you hear about the
tears,
you know,
that it's there pretty much all coming from him.
A lot of people,
a lot of people are even saying that they're crying because I'm not in certain
seats.
That's another thing I've heard people say.
A lot of people I love too that you get that one extra laugh in the,
in the last scene when you're with,
with,
uh,
John Morris is oh yeah,
yeah.
That,
that,
that always gets,
uh,
gets,
the head of the movie.
I think people cause,
cause,
and I think the reason why that gets a good laugh,
you know,
nobody knows what I'm talking about right now.
But I think the reason why that gets a good laugh is because people really want
Russ to,
to make this work.
You know,
they like Russ,
they want them to,
there's so many great characters and multiple storylines with like with the
whole family,
you know,
are different people in that one.
Yeah.
That's a fun,
I'm glad that made the cut.
Yeah,
we were that day.
Um,
all right,
well,
uh,
Shawn Andrews,
thanks again so much.
Thank you.
Um,
go see instant family.
and uh,
that's that man.
One of our best,
we have a rigid,
we have bad ass Photoshop is,
we have amazing people that do remixes and songs.
And one of my absolute favorites is gaping dad.
He's,
he's created some bankers for this show before he just sent in.
Hey,
good morning Julia.
Sorry,
I haven't heard it,
but here it is.
Thank you guys for listening again.
Support sickler.
Go see the movie.
Um,
you know where to find us on tour.
Watch the degenerates on Netflix if you have not already.
And then give,
let's give everybody,
let's give a Garth wave toward cameras.
Here we go.
Good Morning Julia.
Meet Joe.
Just wanted to say hi.
You are so beautiful.
Good Morning Julia.
Meet Joe.
I hope this video doesn't scare you.
What is Julia meet Joe.
Good morning,
Julia.
Meet joke.
I will love you like you've never been loved to watch
Julia
to
my mind.
When you said to me,
you want to go back with your ex boyfriend after you experience me wanting to
know who your ex boyfriend,
please erase them.
Pull your memory.
Don't ever go back.
In the past I could see me fall in love with shit.
Let's go full throttle.
I
Julia,
Julia
throttle,
Julia Joe Childbirth.
Ah.